Hey, hey.
You threw me off the groove.
I was like, you're not supposed to talk back.
I'm here too!
Oh guys, okay, so you guys might see like this little... sorry, I looped the intro because Min and I were sharing secrets.
You're not invited.
They're really good.
Yeah, if only you could have heard what we said.
Oh, you'll never know.
You're gonna miss the FOMO.
Wait, no one said they want the FOMO.
They have the FOMO.
You have FOMO!
Oh, you have FOMO!
What could we have said?
Oh my god, within like five minutes.
I'm gonna tell them right now.
Okay, so you're gonna tell them right now.
Yeah, say it.
Because it's about you, so it's your secret.
What?
You told me stuff too!
But the later half was your secret.
Oh yeah, first half was Doki's secret.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was my secret.
Yeah, so there's two secrets that you don't know.
Two whole secrets.
Oh my god, two whole secrets that you were not...
You were not there for!
How long are we gonna drag this?
We gotta give them all the FOMO.
Yes.
Now that we're in these, we don't have to deal with FOMO anymore.
So we give you FOMO instead.
We give you FOMO.
Yeah.
We can do whatever we want.
Okay, so if you guys don't see the bottom right text on my end, I don't know if you're showing it, Mint, but it says, Oh, I can move myself.
Warning, this version may cause the game to crash.
So it's not our PC.
It might be a Kuso game.
Yeah, it might be.
This is your decision.
Yeah, I suggested the game.
Okay, so this game, I told Mint that she has to start a new game herself as well.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
So like, cause I, cause there's an intro to the game.
So don't click multiplayer, right?
Yeah, don't click, just do new game.
And then you do normal and then you'll be met with like an intro.
Anyway, so those who don't know what Hospital 666 is, it's basically like that, was it Platform 8?
The one with the subway?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it's basically Platform 8.
Actually?
Yeah.
But, or Exit 8.
Sorry, Exit 8.
It's basically Exit 8, but what if we added multiplayer in there?
Woohoo!
How do you even do that?
I don't even know.
We're gonna find out now.
I wonder if it's like 666 floors.
There's 666 anomalies.
How long is this?
How long?
We're gonna be playing up until Doki's new model.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
New skin suit.
Until the new skin suit.
Yeah, yeah.
This is 24 hours by the way.
You know, it was like the...
Surprise!
You know like the Spookies, like jump scare mansion?
Like...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're gonna make it to floor 1000, guys!
Jeez!
Woo!
Is that actually how long that game is?
No way.
Oh, yeah.
The Spookies.
You ever played the jump scare one?
No, no.
Oh, yeah.
I think it is.
I think it's like...
I played it before.
It's up to like 1000 floors.
What the hell?
Cause like every...
And then there's like a lot of...
Cause every 100 you get, it's like a new...
Like a new theme to the...
To the like rooms and stuff.
So it gets spookier and spookier.
Okay, okay.
And at one point, one of them was like...
At one point you go to a floor that's just a fucking maze.
It's more than 1000 floors plus bonus DLC floors.
They made more floors!
More floors!
No, it's...
Oh, wait.
Yeah, they made more floors.
Yeah, there's DLC floors too.
And there's like...
And then like...
And then you get taken to the...
You get taken to like a hospital too.
It's like Spooky's hospital.
Oh, yeah.
And then I also...
While we were like waiting for the stream, I linked Mint a really good...
I linked Mint a YouTuber background and I was like, oh my god, it's perfect.
It's so...
It's the best...
It's actually...
I should have used it today.
Honestly, you should have.
No, that's what they want.
That's what the Wisp want.
Man.
That background?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I'm gonna link it to my chat.
It's this one, guys.
We...
I'll link it to my chat too.
And then you being like, you can recreate that Dr. Horrible thing.
And he can recreate it.
Bro!
Everybody loves it.
Helping that random girl you see at the laundromat roleplay.
It's like...
It's like the...
The...
One of the top five cliches out there.
Top five dreams.
It's true.
You could be that girl.
Oh my god.
There's this...
There's this ghost maid at my laundromat.
My laundromat's haunted.
I'm spooky!
Spooky!
Oh my god.
Because Mint was like, who wants this?
I was like, what do you mean who wants this?
No, no, no.
I said what What led to them creating this?
Who said man?
I really need like a laundromat.
He saw a random girl at the laundromat and he's like, well that could be if only VTubers had this too.
Not enough anime start with a guy meeting a girl at the laundromat.
I'm telling you.
He's like, you know like the West version of weeaboos?
The Westaboo?
Yeah, the Westaboos!
I bet you the person who created it is a Westaboo because they saw too many like American TV shows where it starts off with the laundromat.
He's a Westaboo!
He wishes Japan has more of this.
I'm gonna throw chat in the laundry machine.
I'm gonna throw you guys in.
The perfect RP.
I would make it so that the chat is like, the laundromat is like overlaid on top of chat and then you're just spinning it.
Yeah.
Spinning it.
That's too much work for me.
I won't be doing that.
Okay, I'll do it guys.
Yeah, yeah.
Check Minthe channels out if you want to live your laundromat fantasies.
Wow.
See, that's why I linked you the background.
I knew you'd do that.
You knew it was made for me?
I knew it was made for you.
This background's made for you.
Okay, guys.
How's our volume by the way?
After all that.
Yeah.
Do I sound...
We're gonna start a new game.
Yeah.
I'm gonna start a new game too.
You guys gotta see the intro.
Do I just do any difficulty?
Yeah, any difficulty and then we'll... or do normal.
Yeah.
Actually.
Hell is hell.
Yeah.
Okay.
Are you serious?
I'm starting the game.
Go some balls.
What is this?
Go some balls?
Yeah.
Wait, is this... this is not game footage.
This is a real footage.
Yeah, this is the dev.
Oh.
What's going on?
Go some balls.
Oh my god.
Just so mad.
And now we're in the game.
What?
That's what I needed.
That was it?
Yeah, that was it.
That's what I wanted you to see.
I was like, what the fuck is this?
Now you're in the game too.
All these instructions.
They have like the entire world.
Wait, is he a Vtuber?
Yeah, yeah.
He's apparently like...
Guys, by the way guys.
This developer is single.
Can you make me lag?
I'm sorry.
So, ladies and guys too.
Wait, should I say turn vsync on or off?
I can't remember.
Well, I don't know.
She asked me if she should play on DX11 or Go and she was like, what's the difference?
I was like, I don't know.
Turning it on helped me not lag.
Okay, that's good.
I'm returning to the menu.
All right.
Also, sound guy, turn up mint up a bit more.
Is it better now?
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
Blah, blah, blah.
All right, let me...
I'll invite you.
Let me go to multiplayer host because I don't know...
Did you start off on easy?
No, I did normal.
Okay.
I couldn't tell it because you're like, oops.
And I was like, oh no, what do you mean?
Oops.
All right.
How do I invite you?
All right, give me a second.
I'm sick.
The friends list is like empty for me.
Oh, okay.
So this is fine.
That should be fine, right?
All right.
I can invite you to watch this game.
Wait, can you go to multiplayer and see if you find me in the game?
No, you're not there.
I'm not there.
Okay, let me...
I have no friends.
Oh, okay.
No, I meant like, you know how you go to multiplayer?
Do I show up on multiplayer?
No.
I don't?
Okay.
This is awkward.
What if I press host?
Well, if you're hosting, then I can join you.
Yeah, try me.
Try me.
Okay.
Give me a second.
All right.
Return to menu.
Refresh.
Why don't you exist on my friends list?
That's what I'm saying.
Wait, can you invite me?
You guys, we're not professionals.
Like, we're not...
We're Indies.
You have to have zero expectations on us.
Yeah.
We're Indie VTubers.
Please understand.
It is just us right now.
Yeah.
We're not professionals.
We're not...
We should not be put up to standards when it comes to corporate VTubers.
We're just one person.
I say when I have a team behind me.
Well, I don't.
So I can actually...
Yeah.
Myself and I.
I am.
Friends.
Okay.
We're not even...
Here you go.
I can invite to watch.
What?
I can watch you.
I'm sorry.
I boosted her volume again.
Sound guy.
How do I join you?
All right.
Uh-oh.
Guys, we're...
Give us a sec, guys.
We totally...
Instead of...
You know, we met up 15 minutes before the stream started.
And instead of preparing the stream, we were sharing secrets.
Okay?
We were sharing secrets.
We had our priorities.
It was a juicy, good secret.
Yeah.
If you knew the secret, you would have been like good choice.
You know?
Okay.
I'm gonna do friends.
I'm gonna change my profile settings and see if you can invite me now.
Okay.
Do you see me on...
I think you see me on VTube studios instead of hospital.
Can you...
Oh, wait.
I'm gonna return to the mic.
There's a thing from it on the menu.
Yeah.
I'm gonna do...
Multiplayer.
I'll host.
I'm gonna host a game.
I don't think if you host it you'll show up.
Right?
That's...
Uh...
No, it should be because...
What's the point of hosting it if you don't...
What's the point of hosting it?
How do the other people...
There's no way other VTubers were able to set this up.
That's true!
We can't be stupider than any other VTuber.
Like...
Yes we can Dokie!
Yes we can!
No we can't!
All Vtubers share one brain cell!
There's no way!
All Vtubers have like almost equivalent IQ.
Wait, how do you invite someone on Steam?
Wait, what?
That's what I was telling you to do!
Control...
No, I do that!
Shift tab!
What do you mean?
Shift tab...
Nothing showed up!
What do you mean?
Oh, just kidding, just kidding.
Have you never done shift tab before?
What do you mean never?
Okay...
Now how do I add you?
Alright, you see where Dokie Bird is...
and then you go to invite...
Oh, I can invite you to watch.
Yes, I know what I'm saying!
I'm saying you can invite me to watch!
But it's not even watch the game, it's watch me, Richard!
I mean, don't you wanna watch my face go up the whole time?
The whole time, definitely!
We both have like a solo session of Hospital 666, and we're just watching.
We sync up our Hospital 666 gameplay together.
Obviously.
Or like see who gets to the most floors.
We can make it a competition.
Oooh!
I'm gonna restart my game.
Maybe it's not us.
Guys, maybe it's not us.
We need to play in DX mode!
Oh, was it?
Did we actually have to play in DX mode?
I don't know.
Okay, you're just making shit up.
Oh, I got an achievement for...
for leaving the game.
Oh, okay!
Alright.
Okay, guys.
We're guys.
We can do this, guys.
We can have chat!
No, it's good chat!
You guys get more content!
We could have ended earlier if we didn't have this.
I'm ending the stream right now.
Okay, I'm hosting again.
I'm hosting...
Okay, hold on.
Wait, are you on DX11?
I'm on DX11, yeah.
Okay, I'm on the normal one, so I don't know if that affects anything.
Oh.
Okay, can you see mine?
I see you!
Oh my god!
It's DX11!
All of this lying!
Alright.
I'm joining.
Are you joining?
Hopefully it doesn't crash because it said that this version...
I'm in the floor.
You're on the floor?
I don't see you.
No, I'm in the floor.
Wait, you're in the floor?
Where are you?
I hear noises.
I hear you.
It's me walking on top of you.
I think I hear you.
I'm walking up.
Wait, go towards the man with the hat.
Can I see you?
Go towards the man with the hat.
Okay, okay.
Do you see me?
Yes, you see me!
I'm stuck in the floor.
I'm gonna leave you.
I'm gonna go to the next floor.
Go to the next floor.
Yeah, go to the next floor.
Wait, wait, wait.
Remember I said layout.
This is what it looks like.
This is what the non- This is what the...
Figure it out.
This is okay.
This is a default.
Just figure it out then.
Figure it out.
Okay, okay.
Alright, I'm gonna...
I'll leave you.
Goodbye.
I see the doors close.
Uh oh.
Where are you?
Where did you go?
I don't know.
I'm still stuck in the floor.
Where did you go?
Are you on the next floor?
I'm on the next floor.
Did you go back?
I'm going up another floor and see if- I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna go back up another floor.
Are you still on the first floor?
I can't even exit to the menu.
Like, pressing escape does nothing.
I'm still on the second floor.
Okay, I'm done.
I'm leaving the game?
Okay.
I'm gonna start a new game.
I'll join you.
Maybe that'll work.
Okay, okay.
I'm not doing the DX.
I'm joining normal.
I'm hosting.
Okay.
Sound guy, I turned down mint a little bit.
Is it better now?
We're still adjusting sound while figuring out how to play this game.
It's okay.
We're in these guys.
Okay.
Can you see me in the game?
No.
I don't see you in the game.
I do not.
How did you see me?
Maybe it was the DX mode.
I'm telling you, man.
I'll go on DX mode.
We'll swap.
We'll just try hosting again.
Okay, wait.
No.
I'll do DX mode.
This is so great, you guys.
Guys, guys, we are professionals here.
This is all because we didn't even test it because she was like, you have to see the new game intro.
That's not true.
We didn't test it because I showed her the laundromat.
Get it...
Get it right.
Sorry, my bad.
You're right.
There's a sequence of events that led to this.
Yeah, yeah.
Are you in the game yet?
I'm in the game, yeah.
Okay, because I don't see you.
Maybe it's because you're...
Oh, wait.
Hold on, hold on.
I'm hosting.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Okay, I also have another idea.
I think it's because your Steam is on...
You don't show what game you're playing on Steam.
Because I've made mine friends only.
So you should make yours friends only.
And then after the stream, we private it.
How do you do that?
What do you mean?
That's... Okay.
You go...
Yo.
What did you learn in the last two... three years?
Everyone did everything for me.
What did you learn in the last three years?
Okay.
Go to Steam.
Click your name.
Go to privacy settings.
Oh, hold on.
Where is...
Wait.
Under my profile?
Okay.
You go to... Yeah.
Go to...
Go to edit profile.
Okay.
Oh, privacy settings.
And then friends only.
Oh, my God.
Mint's playing Hospital 666.
No way.
That actually fixed it?
Oh, my God.
I can see you now.
I'm joining.
Oh, there you are.
There I am.
Oh, my God.
It was the Steam thing all over again.
I can't believe you learned this as an indie.
I'm just getting my feet off the ground.
I've been around for two months.
Come on.
Give me a break.
You.
You guys.
You existed five years ago.
You can't say that.
When I existed, you existed when we were both indies, you able to say that.
Okay you know what?
Doki you need to shave come on.
Ugh.
Come on.
Get out of my way.
Get out of this hospital.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Can we open the door?
Okay.
How do you open the door?
I don't think we can.
I don't think we're allowed to.
Okay, we gotta... Oh wait, that's us!
That's us!
That's our triplet!
We're visiting our triplet at the hospital.
Solid, liquid, solid.
Alright.
We gotta memorize this layout.
We gotta figure out what the anomalies are later.
Okay.
Look at that.
I heard that there's like a thing I can do in multiplayer.
Can I do it?
Oh, I can't.
Yes!
We're at the hospital, Lina!
I'm at the hospital!
That's where you wanna get beat up, in the hospital.
Don't make me put the putty!
I'm in here!
I'm in here too!
We're just spamming the putty.
We're gonna punch you in the balls.
That's what I'm gonna do.
Now I punch you first!
Oh yeah!
Are you gonna make it to the elevator?
There's one there!
Yeah, push me back to the elevator!
I'm gonna make it before you!
No!
Whoa!
Give me!
Wait, wait, wait.
No, I can't!
You can't punch people in the elevator!
Yes, you can!
I'm punching you right now.
I like how we are not checking the anomalies.
We're back to floor zero.
Wait, what are you doing?
We were back to floor zero.
What happened?
Look at the elevator!
What do you mean what happened?
What do you mean?
We're advancing!
We played the game!
Look up!
Boop!
I can't leave you.
I had to do the floor.
Alright.
I don't think there's any anomalies.
Wait, are you getting coffee?
Yeah.
Not for you.
Why get coffee when we can get gamer subs?
I saw it.
Anyway guys, did you guys know that we both have gamer subs?
We both have gamer subs!
Anyway, feel free to use Dokibird for 10% off and only Dokibird.
Or Boomer, which is the cooler, more trendy code to use.
Or you can Or the link in the description.
There's no link in your description.
Yes there is!
I'm getting to the elevator first!
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
Oh we were...
Wait you are!
Okay.
Wait a minute, I think there's an anomaly here.
You think so?
Yeah I think so.
What is it?
I don't think there was two cows...psych.
You can't even press the button when you can't even go!
No!
I can't ditch you!
What's the point?
We have to find the anomaly.
Come on!
I don't know!
Everything looks the same!
Wait, isn't he on the other side?
No he was always here.
No, cause like this is where we started off.
Cause this is where you got coffee remember?
Oh you're right, you're right.
Yeah and then you're like over here and you're like oh there he is.
There's all the medicine.
There's this beautiful vista.
Alright let me read the rules.
You find anomaly, press the elevator button.
30 minutes into the stream?
We played this game!
For 5 minutes!
20 minutes of this game with text support!
If you don't find the anomaly, press the button from the elevator.
Oh from the elevator over on this side.
So if we don't find the anomaly, we just gotta...
Oh we come back here?
Yeah, yeah.
You can use the top button to review the previous floor.
Orange light outside means you're starting from this elevator.
Oh okay so it tells you which elevator you start from.
Wait no if you don't find an anomaly press the button from an... oh so if we find an anomaly we come here.
If we don't find an anomaly we go over there.
It's whatever elevator you start with.
Cause both elevators have the same instruction.
So if we find an anomaly we go up a floor.
I don't think there like... or like...
If we find one, we go here.
If we don't find one, we go down there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No we press the... yeah, yeah.
No it's an E cause there's a restart.
There's a... oh no.
No that's if you wanna go back to the previous floor.
Oh!
Guys see we can lean.
Okay do you think there's an anomaly?
No I think so.
I think we're good.
Alright so... Okay hold on there's five... six doors.
Two, four, six.
Okay one, two, three, four, five, six.
Okay.
That's what I said.
I don't know I'm worried you couldn't count.
You know cause we're VTubers.
They care about our health.
Yeah there's like lots of meds here.
Guys remember to take your meds.
That's all of Doki's meds right there.
Yeah and that...
Yeah, yeah.
Meds is in this room.
It's entire room dedicated to her.
Okay, okay.
This one is so that she can count.
This one is so she can read.
This one is... this one is so...
I can't beat you up anymore.
What happened?
Oh no I need to take my meds.
I've lost control of my arms.
This one is so my imaginary friend will finally disappear but I didn't take it.
That's why it's all here.
Why can't I punch you?
Alright let's just go up and see what happens.
Cause I didn't take my meds.
Okay we go... we go up.
I think we're... wait what's that?
I think we're good.
Alright we'll see.
We're just gonna go to two.
We're gonna go to two?
Yeah.
It's not moving.
Oh!
It's back to zero.
I knew we fucked it up.
There's no... there was...
What did we mess up?
Okay wait so this is zero so we can figure out what...
Oh yeah yeah yeah.
Okay so...
Water.
Okay exit side.
The meds are still here.
Water.
There's two trash cans.
Did you count it as six doors?
Did you count... yes I counted as six doors.
I just wanted to be sure.
Okay it's cafe cappuccino.
Cafe con...
con... what's it called?
Panal.
I think we can go up the floor.
I think this is what... I think this is what pastry zero looks like.
Maybe this side.
Yeah maybe this side.
One.
We can pay attention.
We are VTubers.
There's two of us.
Yeah.
This is the amount of like five people.
This is a...
This is a one to four player game.
Okay it's not our fault we're missing two players to help us.
Was this always here?
Yeah this was always here.
Okay.
I've seen this before.
And there was always like two...
I don't trust her.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay then let's stay on this elevator.
Let's stay over here and press the button.
If you don't trust me.
I mean the guy is...
Oh!
Oh my god there's an anomaly!
What's the anomaly?
This guy is running!
What?
Oh my god!
Are you sure?
Wait what do you mean am I sure?
Do you not see it?
No he's standing still.
Wait actually?
Yeah.
Are you sure?
Are you gaslighting me?
I have photographic proof.
I'm glad I'm streaming.
A photo means that it's a photo.
It's a snapshot.
A photo isn't animated.
That proves my point.
No chat I took my...
You guys come on believe me.
Come on look at him.
He's running!
It's not running right?
It is running right?
It's not.
I don't see it.
I'm looking at the stream right now.
It's not running.
Yes!
Use your eyes!
I can only see it five frames per second.
So...
Wait so then that means we go back to this one right?
Yeah we go back and we like go up.
Yeah.
So like you know how like...
You know how like some camera, like some video cameras can only see like certain frames?
And then...
So like you can actually have like a video of like a bird whose wings are just like...
Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
Those are my eyes.
Right?
I think you need to get help for that.
Oh we're at two!
We did it!
That was me.
We did it.
This is a team game.
It's a collab.
What you accomplish is what I accomplish.
Oh my god and now he's green.
He's not running at all.
Alright.
I am looking at the calendar.
Medical...
Center first.
Everything looks the same.
Yeah.
You know what I think you know who...
Wait!
There's three clocks!
Oh there's... wait wasn't there always three clocks?
Oh there's...
wait wasn't there always three clocks?
I only saw one before.
Maybe that was the other one.
That was the anomaly.
Wait.
Maybe... Oh I think it is three clocks is the anomaly.
Yeah.
So we go up from here.
See we're doing so good!
Teamwork!
We!
We're doing so good guys!
Teamwork!
I think you know what?
You know who can be our third and fourth player?
Who?
Chat.
Yeah.
Oh true.
Chat.
Oh look!
See!
One clock!
Yeah!
Oh my god.
I think we're really good at this game.
I think this game is too easy.
Yeah this game is weird.
It's not like we fucked up like three times before we figured it out.
The royal we.
Yeah sure.
I don't think there's any anomalies this time.
It doesn't look like it.
Well you said that last time and there were three clocks!
Look I didn't look behind me!
How many doors?
Doki how many doors are there?
Six.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
See I can count too.
She took her meds everybody.
Yeah I took my meds.
You see?
See?
Up we go!
Come on!
I can't go up a floor without you!
What are you doing?
Okay.
Don't go back to zero.
Wait does it go back to zero?
Yeah it goes back to zero.
We lose.
I don't even know how many floors it's supposed to be.
I don't know.
Four!
We're doing it!
Alright.
Everything looks fine.
Okay there's two fire... Wait wait!
The fire hydrants!
There's always been two.
Yeah but then look at the labels.
Weren't they like together?
Like the same label?
Oh I don't know.
But also wait we started on the other side.
Is that normal?
No we went here.
We came to this elevator cause there was no anomaly.
So we started on that side.
Okay okay okay you're right.
Okay.
Check the meds.
Hmm.
I like how it said fire hydrants and you agreed with me.
What's... Oh fire hydrants.
I told you chat!
Oh!
There's a... There's there's there's there's!
Oh the water!
It's leaking.
Oh my god!
Wait does somebody... What's going on here?
Wait okay that's...
Why is there... Why is there water and why is there blood here?
Why is there blood on the... Yeah!
And it's old blood too cause it's dark red.
Ooh.
Ooh somebody like stubbed their toe or something.
I think that is a pretty extreme stubbed toe.
I think...
So we go in this one right?
No we go on the other... Don't we go on the other one where there's an anomaly?
Okay let's read the rules again.
I'm confused!
I don't remember how we did this.
I...
Okay.
Oh my god the VTuber is a piano.
And you find the...
elevator... Anomaly press the button from the elevator you come from.
Yeah from the elevator you come from.
Oh okay okay okay.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
See?
We're doing it.
I told you this is a team of we.
We got this!
I told...
We.
Alright.
Nice.
Fifth floor.
Chat how many floors is this?
We don't know.
We probably don't know.
They've seen gameplay of this before?
Alright.
Okay.
Let's see.
Alright.
Fire extinguisher.
That looks fine.
Everything looks fine.
The medicine looks the same.
Oh!
Did you see that?
What was that shit?
Get away guys!
Yeah I think this floor was...
I think this floor was...
I think this floor was cursed.
This floor is cursed.
What did you see?
Did you see the skeleton?
The face?
Did you see the face?
Yeah yeah yeah.
No I looked at the painting.
I looked at this painting.
There was a face in the painting.
And I looked at it and I was like, Oh what's this?
Oh it showed up on my whole screen!
Yeah you're just...
I told you this is a we team.
What I do, you get affected.
Why is this guy just sitting here the whole time?
He's here!
He's like triplet!
He's moral support!
Well he needs to be a team player.
He's the one that popped out like five minutes later so we don't talk about him.
I think...
He was in there a little too long.
He goes extra cooked in the oven.
It's fine he's just the silent archetype.
Oh we're like the...
Huey, Dewey and Louie.
Louie?
We're like the three students.
I think it's good.
I think so too.
So we should be at the other side then.
Of the elevator.
We should be on this side.
So there's no anomaly we go to the other side.
How are you still wondering about the rules?
We're on the seventh...
I can't remember this!
We're on the sixth floor!
I'm just finding anomalies okay?
Wait no!
Oh yeah I can find it.
And you don't.
There's barely two rules!
It's too complicated!
What do you mean there's two rules?
It can't be complicated when there's two rules!
I thought you had...
What happened to photographic memory?
I didn't say I had photographic memory!
I didn't say that even once!
Wait what did you say?
You had photographic memory?
Photographic something!
I don't remember.
Well we know you definitely don't have photographic memory.
No definitely not.
I don't see any anomaly.
I don't see anything either.
Let's see.
One, two, three, four, five.
Count the doors!
I counted there's six.
Okay and the fire extinguishers are real.
They look good.
Oh wait!
There's a six on the floor!
What's on this door?
Wait was there a six?
There's a six on every door.
Was that always the case?
I mean I think so.
I can't remember.
Wait.
Chat do your part!
This is a four player game.
You're two player three and four.
What's the point of streaming?
What's the point of streaming if you don't help out?
Do your part.
What are you talking about?
Chat is this real?
I think it's an anomaly.
Guys is this...
Has this always been here?
Guys?
Is there anything on the floor?
No help.
Why do they keep saying that?
Guys you're...
Our fucking live tag is literally called Bird Seeders.
As in backseaters.
Where are my goddamn backseaters?
Where's... okay backseaters is...
There's your time to shine!
You guys know I'm telling the streamer what to do!
Guys!
Tell the streamer what to do!
They said it's an anomaly.
Wait which one did we come from?
Which elevator?
No Elf?
Wait you're right.
Oh no this one.
This one.
The orange.
Whatever has the orange...
Where does it say Elf?
What do you mean whatever has the orange?
Whatever has the orange is where we came from.
What orange are you talking about?
This!
The orange... look up.
Hahaha!
Do you see the orange lighting?
Oh like the orange lighting.
Oh my god.
You just say the orange.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Literally cause it's orange.
What do you want me to say?
I said orange look up.
The orange lighting!
Hahaha!
Oh I'm sorry.
Maybe you were in the womb too long.
Hahaha!
Hey I'm not like him.
And he's a good guy okay?
How would you know?
He doesn't even talk to us.
How do you know that?
So we come here.
We come here.
I think it's an anomaly.
I don't remember seeing the sixes before.
I'm pretty sure the sixes have always been here.
Right?
Chat.
Chat if you don't help us we're going back to floor zero.
Hahaha!
Do you want that?
Do you want to see us back to floor zero?
Hahaha!
The orange.
What does no help mean?
They said yes.
It means no help!
Hahaha!
I don't know.
I'm just thinking maybe there's something in there that says no help.
Hahaha!
They're just being stupid.
No don't call them stupid.
That definitely won't help.
Hahaha!
They like it.
They like it a little bit.
Okay we're taking the risk.
We're taking the risk.
Okay.
Alright it's time.
Oh wait we could have gone to the previous floor.
Oh shit you're right.
We could have gone to the...
Alright here we go.
Oh!
We did it!
Wait I'm looking though.
Yeah it was an anomaly.
I dare you to go in.
I dare you.
Wait there was an anomaly then.
Yeah!
It was the six on the doors.
The one that I caught.
Oh!
I double dare you to go to there.
No I already dared you first.
I double dare you.
Go!
By the rules I double dare you.
No!
I triple dare you!
Hahaha!
I caught Jinx.
Alright goodbye.
Goodbye Mint.
Go up.
Wait I get affected too?
Hahaha!
You closed the game!
Okay this is...
This is a team game.
Don't ever triple...
Don't dare me to do anything ever again.
Hahaha!
I can't move on from her death.
That's not fair Debs!
Debs that is not fair!
She can hold us hostage!
Hahaha!
All F4s out of the game.
Okay um...
Do you wanna host it?
Wait no!
See if you host it.
Continue game and see if we go back to the 8th floor.
Continue.
Does it do it?
Oh wait!
Wait I just pressed continue.
I didn't press host.
Oh I'm on floor 8!
Yeah I told you!
Come here come here.
Okay let me see how I can...
I'm figuring this out!
Get out.
Get in here.
Watch your game.
Hahaha!
Wait you didn't click host!
Uh...
You're in a single player game!
You have to go back to the main menu.
I just pressed continue.
Oh wait.
Oh I see you I see you.
Hold on.
Okay okay I'm in I'm in.
We're at level 8!
Yeah!
Yippie!
Okay no.
Yeah yeah no.
No we're not doing that again.
Hahaha!
You know you got an achievement where like I think the game crashed.
Like that was the...
That was the achievement.
Yeah yeah.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh yeah there was no sixes!
Yeah!
Alright!
Hello friend.
Alright.
Our brother.
Our triplet.
Our Louie.
Louie was the silent one right?
I have no idea.
I don't know.
I don't remember.
Aren't those the ducks?
Yeah they're the... Yes!
It's the ducks!
But none of them were silent!
Yeah!
No one of them was like the newer ducktales.
The newest ducktales.
One of them was like they made one of them silent.
And then one of them was the Sonic's voice actor.
And the other one was Abed.
Abed yeah.
Yeah yeah.
I think we're good here.
I think so too.
I think there's no anomalies.
I don't...
I don't think so either.
Move.
No you move.
We're a team!
You move.
WrestleTuber 20... 20... 25!
Abed in hospital.
Six WrestleTubers.
The sequel to WrestleTuber.
We're going to a hospital.
Real.
Okay.
Alright.
Ten floor.
Ten.
Yeah!
We're so good at this game.
We're really good at this game.
Yeah.
We can see all the anomalies.
I thought the doors would open at some point.
I think that's like you know how there's like a locked part.
I know the doors you can open them but I think you know like when you start a game it's like easy, normal, and locked.
I think the locked portion you can open the doors.
Oh okay okay.
So I was like...
Our vision is terrible.
...we have to get all of you close.
What is this?
No, I can see it.
I think it's right.
May, June, July.
That's right.
We care about your health.
Wait, why is it like, if I'm like halfway in between, it gets like really blurry.
I think you need glasses.
I can see it fine.
Are you on low quality?
Probably.
The game defaults to low graphics.
Yeah, because it's making me lag anyway sometimes.
Oh wait, really?
I opened it up this time in DX.
Maybe it'll help.
Stop it!
She's the violent triplet.
She's the one that mom had to take to the hospital.
I have anger issues.
Wait, so do we go in this one?
Yeah, we go in this one because there's no anomalies.
Okay.
Alright.
Up we go.
Eleven, eleven.
Eleven.
Yeah, it's my soldier genes.
She has the killing gene in her.
Okay, yeah, I think that was an anomaly.
I think, I don't know.
I think we should talk to her.
I can fix her.
Okay.
One clock.
All the coffees.
One brother.
Oh!
Ah!
Don't turn it on me!
I think something's happening on that floor.
No.
Alright.
We're fine.
See?
Everything is fine.
I'm not letting you out of here.
Oh!
Look up.
Yeah.
We are speed running this game.
I think this is a fire hazard floor with all those fire alarms.
They do.
They're a little paranoid.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Alright.
Alright, fine.
This looks normal.
This looks like a normal time.
Yeah.
Everything looks good.
Okay.
Alright.
Coffee.
Gold.
So good.
Our brother is still here.
Wait.
There's still...
Have there always been this many fire alarms?
I haven't been looking up.
Gamers don't look up, you guys.
Yeah.
Gamers don't look...
I think it's...
Wait.
Has there?
I don't think that's...
Now I'm paranoid.
Yeah.
Me too.
After seeing like 200 fire alarms on my phone, I'm like, oh, there's a fire alarm.
I don't know.
Has there always been?
That's a little bit too much, isn't it?
Right.
I feel like a hospital shouldn't have that many.
They wouldn't do two anomalies with this many.
Like with a bunch of fire alarms, right?
I mean, the fucking dev crashed our game.
So I feel like that's something.
Wait a minute.
This door is huge.
Oh, you're right.
The doors are huge.
Yeah.
Or we're tiny.
I don't know.
I just don't know.
Like how we passed like five doors...
Every single...
We went to the very end of the hallway.
We went through five doors and we're like, that seems normal.
We were regressing in our height, in our old age.
We were focused on the fire alarms.
We were focused on the safety.
Oh, wait.
The door is open.
I triple dare dog, dare you to go through that door.
I did it last time.
You go.
How about we do it again?
We're together as twins!
No, you baby!
We do this together!
Why didn't you come with me last time then?
I did!
I was about to get out of that elevator when you went in.
I was gonna...
It's not my fault you didn't wait.
Go, go, go in the...
Oh!
Go to the other one!
What do you mean?
There's more than one?
Yeah, another door opened.
What do you mean?
Okay, I just did that door.
It's your turn.
No, no, no!
We swapped!
Go, Ducky!
Whatever jump scare comes out, you get it too!
Okay, good.
Is this some Scooby Doo shit?
Go get the other one.
Go, go, Ducky!
No, no, no!
It's your turn!
We did the last door together!
Okay, okay, okay.
Come on, come on.
Okay, alright.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh!
I knew it!
It's the same door!
This door opened before!
It is Scooby Doo!
Oh, it's looping!
It's looping.
I told you!
It's Scooby Doo!
What's new Scooby Doo?
Someone's like, this instigator mint cow... Oh yeah, it is cow...
I read that wrong.
Yeah, it is cow or doke.
instigator mint.
You were ready to rip that chatter apart.
I was like, what do you mean, coward mint?
Can we finally have a regular floor?
We've had anomalies back to back.
It's not normal.
He's happy!
He heard some good news!
Solidus!
He's like, gamer subs!
Wow, gamer subs!
Mint just got partied!
He's laughing!
Oh my god, he's laughing!
Where he is?
Is this a dev?
Is this a dev's laugh?
Oh my god, is he getting louder?
Maybe that's why he's single.
Did we win?
What's going on?
What the fuck was that?
It was the SCP!
What was that?
What is that?
It's the SCP!
You put it in the elevator!
Why is he chasing me?
Oh no!
We gotta get to the elevator!
Why are you relying on me?
Oh my god, he's really coming after you.
Wait, I can't get past.
He's blocking me.
He's blocking the way!
It took too long!
I'm trying to figure this out!
What if he turns around?
Oh, he is not turning around.
He's not turning around.
You need to be in the elevator!
Oh, we escaped from the statue.
We escaped from floor 66.
That was 66.
We're at 100!
How did we get to 100?
I don't know.
Oh, wait, that's the door again!
It's the door again!
Is that...
No!
I think this is because we've advanced now.
Oh, it's like a new...
Oh, that's why...
Oh, so there's more to this!
Now we have to memorize this floor.
Okay, there's aspirin.
There's a med kit.
Our brother moved.
You know like the American healthcare system where you have to wait in the waiting room for hours?
He finally got it!
Yeah!
He's next!
He just has to wait another five hours!
He just needs to wait another five hours!
Yeah, he needs to wait another five hours!
But at least he gets a chair now!
He gets a chair?
Everything out here looks the same, I think.
I think it's the default.
Like, oh, this is what it looks like with no anomalies.
I think.
It has to be.
Because we started off on this floor.
Okay, let's look in here.
Okay, there's a big old couch.
There's two chairs.
Oh yeah, memorize that with your non-photographic memory.
Yeah, I'm going to.
Plants, wheelchair...
Two chairs here.
Two chairs, two hospital beds.
There's a chair here.
Vitamins...
More vitamins.
One, two, three, four, five hospital beds.
And then it's like blue and then purple, purple.
Purple, blue.
Alright, we should be good.
We're not going to remember this.
This is why chat's here.
Chat, do your part.
Do your part, everybody.
Do your part.
You love Helldivers too.
Now it's time to...
It's just like Helldivers.
Why is everybody saying no help?
Why don't you...
Are your H keys broken?
What's going on?
101!
Let's go!
Yay!
Okay.
Is our brother in the hospital room?
Let's check on him.
I think everything looks the same out here.
Yeah.
Let's see.
The paintings are the same.
The calendars are...
Oh!
This room is haunted!
Why?
Go check.
Go look, you baby.
Go look!
This room is haunted!
No, it's not!
Yes, it is!
How is it haunted?
Look!
It's your cousin!
I know!
What is he doing here?
What is...
You are such a baby.
She knows.
You do!
I didn't know.
I didn't expect your...
I didn't expect your cousin to come to this collab.
It's actually my face reveal.
Thank you very much.
You have like a fucking ghost sheet underneath.
That's underneath my skin suit.
That's...
So underneath my skin suit is a tomato.
Underneath her skin suit is a Halloween costume.
Underneath her skin suit is a tomato.
Alright.
At least I don't rot.
You know that!
I could be like an alien tomato.
You're not ripe anymore.
Say something.
What about the boomer code?
It's like boomer.
Get it?
Because I say boo a lot.
Then what is the mer for?
What is the mer for?
Mer.
Wait.
Did I just see something in there?
What do you mean?
Oh.
So it's a baby now.
Oh no.
There's definitely something in there.
Oh yeah.
I see that.
Wait.
What?
I went in last time.
No you didn't!
I know what you're talking about.
Yes I did.
Chat would have gone.
I agree with me.
What is that?
We go in together.
As twins we go in together.
Okay.
You go first.
We can't go.
Okay.
You go first.
I'll go in after.
Go ahead.
Okay.
Oh it's a body bag.
Oh it's like crunchy.
It is?
Oh.
Why is it crunchy?
Is he eating cereal in there?
For playing the mortuary assistant again?
Oh gosh.
Please don't.
Alright.
Nice.
I'd rather die again than play the game.
Wait.
So how many floors did we get to before we got to the 66?
I don't remember.
Honestly.
We were...
We definitely didn't do 100 floors.
I think.
Yeah.
Oh.
Wait.
What?
Did you hear that?
Whoa.
Wait.
Another door opened.
Oh.
Okay.
Never mind.
It's closed.
Okay.
It's time to go.
Yeah.
Get out of here.
If there's no one on the wheelchair, it's either a miracle or something happened.
If someone can be a miracle?
Wouldn't it be more of a miracle if they get out of the wheelchair?
Yeah.
But that means somebody just suddenly learned how to walk.
And then they push the wheelchair away.
And be like, I can walk now.
Yay!
I don't need it.
I don't need this.
I don't need this anymore.
Okay.
I think we're safe in this room now.
Was he always staring at us?
Yeah, he was always staring at us.
That's our brother.
No!
No.
He's being sensions, doggy!
He's being sensions!
He's being...
He's just being wacky.
He's just quirky.
He's just being...
Oh, Dewey.
Dewey?
I thought it was Huey!
I remember it.
They all like... the names all blur together.
They truly do.
Stop punching me, I'm sorry.
What are you doing?
You're being too slow!
I was giving you a head start!
I can't punch you anymore, I think.
You've reached your punch limit.
My punch quota.
The punch quota of the day.
Another one?
Anomaly.
What's up with all these anomalies?
We're speedrunning!
Oh my god, put us on speedrun.com!
Yeah!
Yeah, duospeedrun.com!
We're at one hour!
We're so fast!
Oh, you got your punch quota back.
I got my punch back!
Every floor you get a new quota.
Is this a normal room?
Did we get a normal room this time?
Let's see.
I don't see anything.
There's no weird faces in the pictures.
There's no weird faces in the pictures?
If I look at a weird face, you look at a weird face.
No!
I think this is a normal room.
I think so too?
I think we got a normal room for once.
Why is the shadows in this so weird?
Oh yeah, that's true.
My shadow is like going over there.
Has this always been like 0000?
Yeah, yeah.
It has.
Okay, you can barely remember like...
I looked at it earlier!
Alright, aspirin.
Yeah, I think this is normal.
I think this is normal.
Oh my god.
It would be fucked up if it goes back to zero.
No, there has to be like a...
There's no way.
There's like 100.
There's like a checkpoint.
Yeah.
Yeah, 100 must be like our checkpoint.
I think we did it.
Right?
I'm scared.
We must have done it.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
107.
Oh my god.
We finally got to see the other side.
The other side of the...
After so long, we've been like...
We've been stuck in there for the longest time.
Oh, anomaly.
What's the anomaly?
What?
What did you see?
What was it?
He chased after me, Doki!
What?
He got up and...
He got up and he moved.
He didn't need the wheelchair anymore.
There was no one there.
He ran.
He was running.
I think he didn't take your meds.
He ran at me!
Oh, that was Doki up.
Oh, wait.
I mean...
What happened?
You saw me!
I'm sorry.
I'm
sorry.
I'm sorry.
What did you see?
Okay, but there was an anomaly.
What?
The wheelchair was shaking.
But then I thought he got up and ran at me.
But it wasn't him.
I think we were in the hospital for a human.
He saw me.
It was like, he's chasing me.
Oh, wait, there's bodies in here.
There's bodies in here.
Oh, there's bodies in here.
You bitch!
Don't you want to see the bodies move?
I already saw them.
Let me rest.
109!
Give it up for 109.
Someone in the chat was like, I know him.
Doki can be something, but calling her an anomaly.
SCP Tomato.
Oh my god.
Everything seems fine this time.
Are we not going to check the room?
You went in there, didn't you?
You don't want to do the room anymore?
I don't want to do the room anymore.
You still have the room.
I never left the room.
You still love going to the room.
I hate you.
Wait.
Oh, okay.
The wheelchair is here.
It was here and it was like shaking.
Oh, so that was the anomaly.
It was the wheelchair.
It was, but good thing.
Good thing.
Anomaly.
I don't think there is any.
I don't think so either.
Is it good?
Yeah.
I think so.
Which would suck because we are about to hit a mile.
We are about to hit.
We are about to hit number 110.
110 baby.
110.
Let's go.
Is the light always like this?
Oh no, that's the orange light.
The orange.
It's the orange light.
You can't even keep your own story straight.
You thought the person running after you was me.
I don't know.
I don't know what to expect.
May, June, July, we care about your health.
Okay.
Everything looks normal.
I think so too.
I don't see anomalies.
Anomalies.
Coffee.
The vending machine looks the same.
Paintings look the same.
I think we are good too.
Oh!
Look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look.
Come in here and look up.
Oh, run, run, run.
Okay.
We are running, running.
We are running, running, running.
We understood the rules.
We are running.
Up we go.
I like how we have a retry.
We are like, we don't know but like...
But let's just re-roll.
It's like, gotcha, we re-roll.
The anomaly.
Let's see.
Five extinguishers seems normal.
Exit seems normal.
Yeah.
Paintings seem normal.
Paintings.
The meds are all there because someone is still not taking their meds.
It's not me.
I don't know.
Wait, is something...
Yeah?
Is something different in here or am I crazy?
Let me check.
I mean, we all know you are crazy but like...
But am I like crazy?
Are you like, Manhera Manhera?
I'm like, are you the good Manhera or the bad Manhera?
What is the good Manhera?
The ones that are like, she might be crazy but I think I can fix her.
And then the bad one was like, there's no fixing her.
There's no fixing her.
I'm just here for the wild ride.
I think we're good here.
I think so too.
The coffee all look the same.
There's one clock.
There's all the coffee stuff.
Um...
The calendars look the same.
Yeah, I think we're fine.
Doki makes me Manhera.
What do you mean?
I...
I literally taught you how to use your own steam.
If anybody's going Manhera.
Okay, yay floor 1-1-2!
1-1-2 baby!
I think we are going to 666.
No way.
There's no way.
Why are we at 112 floors?
We are already at 100.
Yeah.
Um...
Maybe it'll go from 112 to like 500 or something.
Yeah.
We just skip two other floors.
The dev did not program enough.
There's no way there's enough anomalies to make 666 floors.
There's no way.
Maybe like next patch update we add in more floors.
It's just like the spooky...
The DLC floors.
Let's see.
I don't think I see anything.
The ceiling looks normal.
The meds are still there.
No one's taking them.
Wait, wait, the water cooler.
Oh look at that.
My chat's helping now.
What water cooler?
The water cooler.
What about it?
Is it this water cooler?
Which water cooler?
Oh the room.
I even walked up to the other ones.
Oh my god.
666.
666 just like the doors.
See look at that.
My chat is doing their part.
Thanks chat.
Thanks dragoons.
Wait a second.
My chat said it too.
They said in the room.
Yeah but my chat said the water cooler.
My chat probably said it too.
And I'm just not looking.
Oh so you're not reading your chat?
Yeah I'm neglecting them a little bit right now.
Sorry chat.
It's okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
They're not so needy.
Not like the dragoons.
Whoa!
The wisps are just as needy as the dragoons.
Stop saying she hates us.
Stop!
Oh my god.
You're supposed to be chill.
She's supposed to be chill.
Okay no.
We care about your health.
The medical center.
I think this is a...
Fire.
Exit.
Water.
Fire.
This seems to be an okay room.
Guys.
I think so.
Besides you.
What's that supposed to mean?
We're here for you.
You haven't taken your meds since floor one.
We're here for the both of us.
Maybe all the triplets are fucked up.
Alright.
One one four!
Yay!
We're doing it.
We haven't failed even once.
This is crazy.
Yeah.
Just like for VOD watchers.
Skip the first 30 minutes.
But we haven't failed once.
Hey June July.
Alright.
I feel like the calendar would have anomalies soon.
Because I feel like the words are gonna change on the calendar.
Oh!
There's an anomaly.
Anomaly?
What's the anomaly?
Go check.
See if you can find it.
Okay.
I found it.
You find it.
Exit.
Oh!
There's the devs!
Is that the dev?
I think it is.
It's the dev on this PC.
Oh you're right!
Oh my god!
He's watching his play!
He's actually watching.
He's actually moving.
Oh my god!
He tapped into us.
He's smiling at you.
He's watching us.
Oh my god.
Is this like what it feels to like when we see our chat watch us at the panels?
This is what I see when I like end the stream.
Now it's just sad.
Oh my god!
1, 1, 5!
5!
We're here!
Okay.
Nice.
When are we getting another SCP?
Yeah.
Where's your other SCPs?
Okay.
Checking the calendar.
Seems normal.
May, June, July.
We care about your health.
Min, we care about you.
You gotta please take your meds.
Oh shit!
AHHHHHHHHHH!
He wasn't there before!
Yeah I know!
I was just like I did a double D.
I was like what the fuck!
Where did he come from?
He's just there at the door.
Look he cares about your health Min.
He cares about your health.
The shadow man.
He's here.
Okay.
This is a really tall hospital.
Not gonna lie.
I know.
How many sick people are there?
I think they have other things to worry about.
They need to make a hospital this big.
I feel like it's like the only hospital in the country.
They've demolished all the hospitals.
And just kept this one.
I think we're fine.
We haven't even been in here.
Has there always been this many plugs?
Outlets in the hospital?
I don't know.
I wasn't looking.
You've been to a hospital before.
I have.
Oh my god I thought that was you.
Wait he's too big!
I was gonna say he looks different.
He looks huge.
Oh my god.
He drank a lot of milk.
Brother.
We're all supposed to be the same size.
No wait.
I think we're just small.
We're small.
Are we getting smaller?
I think we are.
No!
We gotta hurry back or we're gonna go back to the room!
Oh my god.
It also shrunk.
Oh my god we like grew back up.
Oh no.
It's SCP time.
What SCP is this?
Where are you?
I saw a maze for a second.
Wait where are you?
There you are.
There's things coming out!
Wait there's bodies coming out!
What's the maze rule?
That's not it!
Ah!
Run from me!
Wait you're dead?
He touched me!
He touched me and I died!
You just have to avoid him!
Oh my god.
There's a ton of them!
Run around!
Run around face through them!
You're a ghost!
Oh they stopped.
Hey there.
Oh!
I gamed.
I'm a gamer.
Okay so I saw the dead end and I ran back to the dead end.
Why did you do that?
You put me in a maze you might as well just say goodbye to me.
We have a new room!
Oh it's 200!
We're at 200!
Yeah we have a new room it's at the end this time.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Wait no no it's... yeah it is.
It's the other door.
Look I'm directionally...
Wait so this is all the normal.
Yeah this is the normal and we gotta figure out the...
Oh my god.
Oh there's our brother!
He's finally got into the...
He's not even on the exam table!
He has a bullet in his neck!
He has a tumor in his neck!
Oh my god what happened to you?
Brother!
Brother no!
This is how we find out!
No at floor 200?
Oh my god!
Is that a bullet or a tumor?
I can't tell.
What is that?
He got shot in the neck?
That's why he can't speak!
Brother no!
No brother!
You have to talk to us!
Brother we're worried about you!
The doctors...
You just need to wait 10 more hours and the doctors will be here to help with the surgery!
It's just a bullet don't worry about it!
Don't mind the fact that we're here!
Don't mind the fact that this is where all the dead bodies go brother!
It is possible to save you!
Yeah why is the morgue in the same place?
That's the x-rays?
Yeah!
Okay...
We're back baby!
Oh no!
We're back!
So these... there's three open.
Okay one... no there's four.
Three wide open.
This one.
Oh I'm sorry for the details.
I wanted to...
provide the details.
I mean if we're like looking at...
Okay then it's not four it's...
Five... six open!
It's six open if you want the details!
There we go!
That's what we want!
We're here to spot the anomalies!
I really like that they kind of try to spruce up this room with some plants.
Oh yeah plants and be like...
You know you might be dying but at least there's like something to look at.
Yeah.
And the smiling... the smiley face right here.
The smiley face?
Everything's okay!
You're not gonna die!
We have the...
What is this?
Oh no it's French.
Sous aux lectrices.
Oh...
You like my French?
It's authentic.
Sous?
Oh sans sorry.
Sans!
You don't know that!
You don't even speak French!
Ah oui!
Parlez-vous franais?
Je m'appelle Doki.
Ah oui!
That's how you say Doki in French by the way.
Doki.
Je m'appelle Doki.
It's like...
Boku no namae wa Toby Fox.
Let's say that!
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh this is apparently CPR.
Cause they're kissing.
Yeah yeah yeah they're kissing!
We're gonna do that to our brother?
Preparation and execution.
We're gonna kiss the bullet away.
We're gonna suck it out of his throat.
Like a vacuum.
That's what brothers do!
They suck the bullets out of his throat!
Yeah!
Get yourself a true brother!
That'll suck the bullet out of your neck!
If you don't kiss your brother for him to leave you're not a real brother.
That's true.
Wait was that always there?
The yellow sign thing?
Oh I don't know actually.
I think so.
Was that always there?
You sure?
Um there's an anomaly.
Oh shit.
Why are you running backwards?
Oh my bad.
Why did you run forward?
I didn't die!
Like someone.
You didn't even see the body bag.
I literally said there's an anomaly.
I saw it first!
Yeah but you stayed there!
No I literally you pushed me back into the room!
I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't think I pushed anybody back.
That is he says she says.
He says she says.
Sally sells cheese shells at the store.
I can't even say that.
You can't even say it!
What is it then?
What is it?
Sally sells sea shells by the sea shore!
Yes!
She says she says.
Sally sells sea shells by the sea.
I'm sorry!
I was in ESL class as English is my first language.
But English is your first language.
Yeah I was put in ESL when I was younger.
Doctor says I'm special.
Yeah you needed it.
You needed it clearly.
I think this floor is good.
Yeah I think so too.
I don't think there's any anomalies.
I don't think so.
Two oh three!
Bing!
Yeah!
That took a lot longer.
It was actually deciding if we were right.
Do we give her that one?
They don't want to.
They don't want to give us the point.
They're like I don't think they actually figured it out.
I think I heard something.
Inside the room?
I don't know.
It sounded like flickering lights or something.
We care about your health.
May, June, July.
This calendar has been the same thing over and over again.
Over and over again.
When is there like something new on the calendar?
Brother.
Why is there still a bullet in your neck?
Please talk to us brother.
That's all we want from you.
We just want you to talk to us.
We miss you brother.
We miss your singing brother.
The meds are fine.
I think everything on this floor is fine.
The coffee is fine.
The clock still says 6.
30.
666.
There's no sixes on the doors.
I was like why is my chat doing smileys?
Yeah.
Up we go.
2, 0, 4!
4?
Yeah!
We see the elevator drop down.
I know.
I would literally cry.
We went through the maze.
Oh, anomaly.
What's the anomaly?
Come on, let's go inside.
No, we gotta see it together.
I saw it, I saw it.
You go see it.
Oh no, he's sad!
Laughter.
No!
He's sad now!
He realized it's terminal.
He's a bully.
Oh well.
We can have another brother.
Oh my god.
Chill out.
What happened?
What's going on with you?
I'm letting my issues out because my brother's dying.
Come on.
Come on, come on, Doki.
We gotta leave the elevator.
We gotta go find the anomaly.
Yeah, that's right.
You can't hit me back on the back of the elevator.
I'm in the corner.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's see.
Oh, he's happy again!
Oh wait, what the fuck is that?
Oh!
Go in.
What's the anomaly?
Go closer to it.
You found it.
No, no, no, no.
That's not the rule.
Because last time you didn't do that either.
What are you talking about?
We do it together.
We're a team.
That's all we have now.
Our brother's dying.
What are you doing?
Come on.
Get over there.
I don't think I can smack you anymore.
You reached your quota.
Get closer!
It's just a man with a brain.
It's the opposite of us.
Is he like clipping through?
You see, class?
That's where our brain is.
I actually can't tell if it's like a head.
It's like he's like clip through.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
He's like clip through.
Alright, come on.
Let's get closer.
Come on.
What do you want to say?
Hi.
I think he's just chilling there.
He's just smiling.
Wait, I don't think...
Is that a brain or is he wearing like a handkerchief on his head?
Yeah.
It's a handkerchief.
I was like, wait a minute.
That looks like claws.
I can't believe it.
He didn't come after us.
Yeah, he was just saying hi.
He looked really like sinister.
Yeah, he was just like, hey.
That's what he does on his free time.
Alright.
Okay, it's your turn to go to that room.
I'm going to look at the other anomalies.
Oh, I found the anomaly.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Why can't we do this together?
What am I?
Come on.
It's the anomaly.
What the fuck is that?
Wait, that's just a kid.
It's just a kid.
It's literally just a kid.
They get like, kid PNG on Google.
No, it's a kid.
It's just a kid.
What's he doing there?
It's like a doctor's, like the children's hospital.
They put it in to make it seem more friendly.
They put a child in the lights.
It's like a skibbity.
A skibbity?
Oh, no.
This is when boomers try to relate to the young people.
They just say, you hate kids.
Skibbity.
You can't just say skibbity.
Skibbity all the time, Doki.
Oh my god.
Go in there, I dare you.
What do you mean I dare you?
Oh, what the fuck?
I triple dog dare you.
What the fuck do you mean go in there?
Come on, go in there.
You got his chest and them.
Oh, you met your punch quota.
Don't make me punch you.
I know you met your punch quota.
Oh, it's back up.
Okay, I guess.
I guess I can go in there.
I mean, if you insist.
If you insist.
Is it working?
Oh my god.
I triple dog dare you to jump over that cliff right now.
You were too baby.
You couldn't even go in.
Oh, yeah.
As the blades are rolling down.
Oh my god.
You're too baby.
I went in.
I went in the door shut.
It was like so crazy.
Well, it wasn't you went in.
I punched you in.
Yeah, that's really true.
These rooms always have the anomalies.
They're kind of crazy.
Yeah, I think it's because like, I think like the devs ran out of ideas for the main area.
So they're just put it all in here now.
Maybe we've exhausted all of them.
Like we've seen all of them.
They're like, please leave the hospital.
We're done here.
I don't think there was an anomaly.
Does anyone see anything?
Water.
I'm triple checking.
I'm gonna go look at the sign.
The caution sign.
I'm gonna look at the painting again.
I think it's done.
Wet floor.
Water.
This floor is always wet.
Where's the fucking janitor?
What do you mean this floor is always wet?
There's a wet sign.
It's been here since the beginning.
Why is every floor wet?
Wait, no we're not.
What do you mean?
Has this page always been like peeled off?
What page?
This one.
Has this page always been peeled off?
I think so.
I don't think they would do something that subtle.
Okay, no it's this.
666!
You will never get 666!
Never get 666?
Is that what it says?
Yeah, you will never get 666!
Oh you will never get 666!
666!
Oh yeah, we're gonna prove you wrong!
We told you this was a 24 hour stream!
Oh my god, it's actually gonna go to 666.
I told you!
This floor is 666!
You know, I honestly thought this was gonna be a short game.
I thought so too.
I thought it was gonna be like 20 floors.
Just like the exit 8.
But we're at 666.
We're actually going to 666.
But we like jump a lot.
That's true.
Isn't it the plants?
We're both looking at the anomalies together!
Yeah!
I'm finding them!
I found all of them.
I found every single one so far.
You haven't even found them!
This is a Wii game!
You were like, oh I told you!
You!
Okay, okay.
You think there's no anomaly?
I don't know.
I think there's no anomaly.
Oh.
Did you find an anomaly?
No, I think there's no anomaly.
I don't trust you.
I'm going back.
I'm going back to cover your tracks.
Mint!
Is there an anomaly in this room?
Yes!
What is it?
Can you tell me what the anomaly is?
The X-Ray!
Yay!
Can you say X-Ray?
X-Ray!
The X-Ray in French.
What?
Say that again!
Can you say the X-Ray in French?
The X-Ray?
The X-Ray!
Up we go!
Oh my god.
You're like Boots in Andorra.
Okay.
I think all the anomalies are just in that room.
I was like, boom!
And I jumped.
We didn't even say anything.
We just turned around.
Okay, here we go.
At least I run out of the elevator.
You just walk out.
You crawl out like a baby.
That is not true.
I was hydrating.
You're waiting for me.
You're waiting for me to run into anything.
I was not.
Nuh-uh.
Oh, you're typing.
I'm coming to this room.
You're in the room with me?
Who's the baby now?
I thought that was you again.
I thought somebody was running at you again.
I don't think there's an anomaly this time.
We don't know yet.
I'm pretty sure.
There really is nothing in the outside.
Yeah, I think all the stuff is now just in this room.
Hey, that makes it easier.
It really does.
And before they add, they actually add one anomaly outside.
I'm sorry.
Is there anything?
I really don't see anything.
I don't see anything also.
My chat was like, look up.
But there's nothing up top.
Oh, are we supposed to look up?
Gamers don't look up, you guys.
If somebody adds stuff upstairs, then they're not a real gamer.
They're a poser.
Check behind the standing whiteboard.
You know what?
You're right.
I was looking there earlier and I forgot.
Wait, what?
What do you mean look up?
They keep saying look up.
Stop, don't... I am not up.
They said look up!
I'm looking up!
There's like something up top.
Are they gaslighting us?
I think they're gaslighting you, yeah.
There has to be.
Everybody's saying look up.
No, they're saying gamers, subs.
Oh, yeah.
Anyway, check out gamers, subs, code, don't keep it.
It's called boomer.
Oh, wait, there's no... I think we're good.
No, everybody keeps saying look up.
I don't know.
They're fucking with us.
They're not saying that to me.
I think they're fucking with you.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, you're right.
You're right.
I think so too.
So I guess there's no anomalies.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
Everyone keeps saying the smile.
What smile?
The smile in the room.
No, let's go back and look at the room.
I can't.
They keep saying they missed it.
They're yelling that I'm blind.
What?
They're saying we're blind.
My chat is not saying that.
Are you sure you're not looking at your chat?
I am looking.
There's nothing here.
What is your chat saying about my chat?
They're saying she's getting gaslight.
Everyone's saying the smile.
What do you mean by the smile?
Where's the smile?
Don't punch me.
Don't take your impression off me.
What are you saying about the smile?
What are you talking about?
It's dokey.
Dragoons smh.
So true chat.
Dragoons, are you really going to let the wist say that about you?
Punch me.
Fight, fight, fight.
You know the meme?
The Simpsons meme with the monkeys fighting?
And then the people...
Surrounding them with money.
Okay, we're going to level 12.
It's going to be level 12.
212.
Oh, I was getting gaslighted.
You again?
Don't take it out on me.
You're really going to let the wist do this to you.
The wisps are good.
May, June, July.
We care about your health.
Wait a second.
Oh, I thought something was different.
I think everything looks the same.
There's outlets here.
Son os electricer.
Wait.
We're the same height.
We're the same height as our brother.
Yeah, everything looks the same.
Oh!
Wasn't this on the other side?
No, it was always there.
Never mind.
Yeah, the car was always there.
No, I meant this.
Oh, the chair?
No, this... whatever this...
No, this was always here.
Never mind.
It was always here.
I was thinking about this thing.
Like the little camera thing.
You're gaslighting yourself.
You can't trust nobody, not even yourself.
Not even yourself.
These games make you paranoid, man.
They're like, where's the anomaly?
Where's the fucking anomaly?
But like...
Everything looks the same.
Yeah, I think so.
I don't think there's any difference here.
It looks normal.
Yeah, this looks normal.
I guess we go.
Alright, here we go.
Are the tiles bigger?
I don't think so.
Can we look up?
I'm looking up!
I looked up!
I looked up.
We're good.
Alright, here we go.
Next floor.
Yay!
2-13!
Wait, people are saying there was an extra light switch.
Uh oh.
Don't say that.
2-13!
See, you're gaslighting too!
What the hell!
The Winsome gaslighting you too!
Oh, I found the anomaly.
I found it too.
Yeah, let's go.
I don't wanna go in that cold.
I think our brother is getting his operation right now.
Finally!
That means it's been 5 hours.
He went through 2 different rooms.
I don't even know what light switch they mean.
I think they just made it up.
Oh, these two maybe.
So there's always been 2.
Brother!
Did they take away the bullet?
I think they did.
I think he looks a little happier now.
I'm pretty sure.
You see that smile?
There's a QR code!
Is it to this YouTube channel?
I know it.
It's getting darker.
Is it?
Oh, it is.
Scan that QR code!
Where does it go to?
It's fully dark now.
Where does it go, guys?
Scan it!
I bet you it goes to...
It goes to like YouTube.
My affiliate link.
It goes to...
It goes to men's gamer subs.
Someone just said, I got a virus.
My chat was like, hold still.
We can't scan it because you're moving.
It's a YouTube link.
Oh, it's a Rickroll.
No way.
It's a Rickroll.
Wait, it has?
No way.
Hold on.
Are you going to scan it?
Is it actually a Rickroll?
It's like a 5 second...
It's like a 5 second clip.
It's unlisted.
Oh, what is it?
I don't know.
It's a black screen.
I can't figure out.
Put that volume up.
I'm trying.
Oh my god, it's disappearing.
What the fuck?
What did you say?
Can you hear me?
I heard it.
I heard it on your end.
What?
I can't hear him.
Wait, play again.
I'm turning off my noise gate.
Okay.
Can you hear me?
I'm trapped in the game.
Oh, I'm trapped in the game.
Oh my god.
There's another Vtuber in here?
I think we need to leave.
How dare they come to our stream.
This is an exclusive collab.
What are you trying to do coming to our stream?
In our game.
You thought it was a Rickroll?
People in chat were saying it's a Rickroll.
I didn't know they didn't even bother to scan it.
Look, see I went into that room first because I'm brave.
Fuck you.
Alright.
This looks the same.
Our brother's been possessed.
Wait, what do you mean?
Stop punching me.
Oh my god.
He's looking at me.
He's obsessed with me.
Oh my god.
Brother, no.
It's not Alabama.
Brother.
That bullet's sitting...
Don't say that.
Wait, isn't it normally at 16 that we get to the...
When do we get to the...
I think at 16 we do.
Yeah.
Yeah, so we have to get through this one.
I think everything looks the same.
You say that literally two seconds into walking into the room.
Everything looks the same.
That's how much I need.
That's all the intel I need.
It's one room.
You would have never noticed, brother.
Yes, I would have.
If I looked right, I would have seen it.
No, you'd never have noticed.
You never pay attention to brother anymore.
You never pay attention to him.
You were the one that was supposed to look after him when he got shot.
I can't.
You know what?
I think you were the one who shot him.
You're the one who shot him.
You play Apex.
You knew I was going to the supermarket for mom.
You knew I was going to the supermarket for mom to buy us groceries.
You knew.
I think there's actually no anomaly.
Brother was in your care when this happened.
That was trapped in the haunted hospital.
We only call him brother.
He doesn't even have a name.
Brother.
It's because he can only say brother.
So we named him brother.
He's like a Pokemon.
He's like go brother go.
Brother.
There's no anomalies right?
I don't think so.
Yeah.
It's like the Sean situation all over again.
Sean.
Press F to brother.
Are we about to go into the SCP world?
SCP time.
Oh god.
2017.
We fucked up.
Brother.
This is your fault.
No.
Back.
Hold on.
16 floors again.
No no no no no.
What if it goes back to like 100?
We can just go back up again.
What does it go up?
Oh.
What did you do?
I.
Okay.
I don't know.
When an elevator just gives us question marks.
I don't think that's a good sign.
Okay you go brother.
Wait.
The elevator doors closed on the other end.
Yeah.
What did you do?
I'm going.
Why is the elevator closed?
I don't know.
Brother.
Brother what did you do?
Brother what did you do brother?
Brother.
Why are you not going inside brother?
I don't see anything in here.
Is it like patient zero?
Are we back to zero floor?
Is that it?
Someone said we're checking your mistake.
Oh.
This is the test floor.
Wait no.
The scale?
The scale was never here before right?
I thought it was.
I even looked at it.
You can review the floor.
This is the test floor.
Oh wait or like the floor that we messed up?
Yeah I think this is the floor we were just at that we messed up.
Oh.
What did we mess up on?
Everything looks...
Oh it was.
The scale was never there.
What?
Oh no.
No I found it.
I found it.
Oh.
They're sad at our mistakes.
Yo this is so messed up.
That's so messed up.
We have to do six.
I think it's a fast speedrun because they're all in the same room.
It's always in that room.
That's true.
Yeah we can do this.
We can still get into speedrun.com.
Oh okay.
We just spammed it.
200.
Okay.
Go.
200.
We got it.
Speedrun.
My screen went black.
Oh no wait can you see anything?
Yeah I can now.
Is there anything in there?
Do you think it's gonna be the same stuff as before?
I feel like it's just randomized.
Alright.
Well that means we know what to look for right?
Yeah.
We've seen majority of it.
We've seen all 16.
Yeah we should know what to do.
Yeah right.
Alright so next floor.
Oh 200 is always the test floor.
Remember that.
Oh you're right.
So there's nothing here.
We're sorry we fucked up so we reverted time.
Oh my god.
Brother we're sorry.
We messed up.
Oh don't push me in.
What floor is it?
It's the saw.
Oh you looked up?
Yeah I looked up.
I wasn't a gamer.
Alright brother.
We're going to get you out of here brother.
We're gonna get you out brother.
Brother is possessed.
Speedrun speedrun.
No why is it 16?
I can't believe on the last floor we fucked up.
I know right.
On the last fucking floor.
That means we have to check the behind the thing every time.
Yeah.
Oh the guy is in the locker.
Maybe they'll give all of them to us.
Maybe all 16 is just anomalies.
I can't believe we know every single anomaly now.
I mean it's easy cause it's like always in that room too.
Where's the replay ability?
Uh.
Oh oh oh oh.
Go go go go go.
Yay!!!
Wait wasn't one of them a girl?
That like shows up.
Oh the body bag.
I know where it starts at though.
I know where it starts at.
The x-rays are upside down.
I'll be the elevator pusher.
Okay you're not gonna be.
Okay we'll take turns.
We'll take turns.
You go next.
Why do you think we take turns?
You're faster.
No, no, no!
I think you're really good at this.
Okay, now you go and I'll press the button.
What if I mess up?
Just go.
Go hurry up!
I run in there!
Oh my god, why are you so slow?
You know what everything is.
You're gonna make me do this!
If you're gonna make me do this, I'm gonna do it my way.
Check behind the whiteboard.
No, there's nothing behind the whiteboard.
I don't trust you.
Oh, yeah, you don't trust me!
Look at that!
You don't even trust me to do your job!
See?
At least I'm meticulous.
I look at these details.
Oh yeah, we gotta go to the other side, right?
Yeah, see?
I was testing you.
I was testing to see if you remember.
Oh, that sucks because now we have to run all the way to the other side.
I know.
Yeah, because what if there's an anomaly?
207!
Seven!
Don't worry, I'll be here.
What if it's the body bag?
Wait!
Why am I going?
Because then we know if there's an anomaly.
Okay.
It is a very far run.
It is a pretty far run.
I'm scared of being in here.
You're peeing in here?
Being in here?
Yeah.
Wait, I think we're good actually.
Oh no, that's the QR code!
It's the QR code.
Oh, it's the QR code?
The guy who's trapped?
See, look.
It would be a waste of time if I ran in there too.
Get out of my way.
How did you know?
I said being, you guys!
It's Doki that brought up the pee!
I can't believe it!
Why do you always bring up the pee?
You go.
Why me?
Run!
Because we're taking turns!
I did not agree to that.
I hope it's the body bag.
If it's the body bag, we have to do this all over again.
No we don't!
You just run over here.
Get in there!
What if I die?
Go inside!
Oh, it's the sad face.
He's sad.
Oh, okay.
Sad face.
Yeah, he learned it was terminal.
So we have to get a specialist.
One of us is going to get the body bag.
It's going to be really unfortunate.
It's like Russian roulette, but with a body bag.
It really is.
It's your turn.
Did you get the body bag?
I sure hope not.
I know where it's at though in the beginning, so...
It's not fair!
Wait, that's not fair!
You know where it's at!
I'm not going to tell you either.
Wait a second.
What?
I'm not going to tell you.
Are you sure it's not the child?
I'm not the child.
I don't see anything, actually.
Oh, okay.
Check behind the whiteboard.
I did.
Okay.
Are you sure?
I don't think it's anything.
Yeah, it seems good.
Let's go.
If we fuck up, we know who to blame.
You could have checked.
You literally could have taken the two seconds to go in there.
I trust you.
I don't doubt you like you did to me.
I'm sure you know who to blame.
I'm going in.
Your turn.
Alright, my turn.
Go in.
Go inside.
I'm going in.
Nope.
There's nothing there.
Behind the whiteboard?
I checked the whiteboard.
Check for the 666?
I checked the 666.
You will never get out.
There's nothing here.
Are you sure?
Oh, you don't trust me again?
There's no baby face?
No baby face.
Oh, you're coming inside the room too?
I mean, well, I'm right next to it.
Wow.
You don't even trust me.
No, I don't.
I gave like full commitment to all your sources.
I was like, yep, you said there's nothing in there.
Alright, I don't even need to check.
Okay, because it's so long, I'm going to be on the far side of the room.
I think we should go in the next one together.
Alright, you know what?
Let's... yeah, I agree with that.
Yeah, we'll go in the next one together.
We'll do that together.
See guys, this is what friendship is.
This is teamwork.
This is stream work.
Alright.
Okay, let's go.
I'm right beside you.
Okay, I'm just... I'm just...
Hey, why are you looking back?
Why are you looking back?
If you fully trust me, you wouldn't look back.
Oh!
Okay.
We gotta give brother his privacy, you know?
We gotta give him his privacy.
He's getting operated on.
He's getting operated on, you guys.
It's so rude to go in there.
Yeah, guys.
He's like naked right now.
Our brothers won't look...
Okay, let's go again.
Together.
Why do you keep looking back?
I think it's the body bag.
What are you...
It's not the body bag.
There's no child.
I hope it's nothing so that we can get closer to the room.
Yeah, me too.
I don't think there is anything.
I don't see anything either.
Yeah.
I looked up.
Oh.
Whoa.
Thanks for the raid.
I don't know who raided me.
Brother?
Thank you.
All right.
I'm going backwards.
I think we're good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Brother?
Don't worry, brother.
We're gonna make it to the 300th floor.
Yay.
Oh, Blaze.
Thanks.
Thank you.
213.
Now we took turns again.
Oh.
Oh, it's the child face.
It's the child.
Okay.
God damn it.
All right.
Good.
Good turn.
Together, guys.
Together.
No.
It's all you.
What happened to together?
Go on in.
There's no body bag.
Oh, you don't trust me.
You're everything.
You go for it.
It's 666.
It's the 666.
Yeah.
I think the next one's the body bag.
The next one has to be the body bag because we really have to wrap.
It's your turn.
Oh my God.
No.
It's okay because if it's the body bag, I can see it from here.
It's your turn.
I'll let you know immediately.
I'll be next to the button.
It's the body bag.
Oh, my God.
At least we're on this side, you know?
Yeah.
Okay.
This one has to be the smiley then, right?
Because we haven't gotten...
Behind the...
Yep.
There it is.
Oh, my God.
That's so cheap.
The last floor with the smiley to make... he must have done it so that the last floor would always be like the smiley face to make you think there's nothing.
Right?
SCP time.
No.
It's SCP.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
What's happening?
What's that?
What is that?
I can't see anything.
Oh, it's like...
What the hell?
A zombie...
It's like the Unity Store zombie.
But there's like a guy blocking the door too.
There's two of them.
There's two zombies.
Okay.
Wait.
We got to split up.
This way.
Okay.
I got the...
The zombie is chasing me.
I'll sacrifice myself to you.
Ah, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit.
What do you mean, shit?
I got started chasing...
Getting chased by a zombie.
Man, this is up to you.
He fucking ran me.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe you walking dead me.
What do you mean?
You let that guy kill me.
I literally watched him bum rush you.
Oh, we have a new floor.
We have a new door.
All right.
Time to see you.
Here we go.
What's all different in this room?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
He's over there.
This is a...
Brother.
He's a doctor now.
He's a doctor.
He's at the...
He's finally...
He's getting his diagnosis.
Wait.
Oh, gosh.
This is gonna be so bad.
We have to check behind these curtains.
Oh, no.
There's gotta be...
There has to be somebody behind these.
There's gonna be something on the computer.
There's gonna be people behind.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Let's see.
So, like, he's waiting for the doctor to tell him what the surgery was like.
If the surgery was a success.
A success or not.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's the operation time.
Post operation, brother.
We're here for you.
Just remember.
We're holding your hand, brother.
We're holding your hand.
We're here for you, brother.
Washing your hands.
Drying your hands.
Isn't that, like, kind of unsanitary?
The hand dryer.
The hand dryer next to...
Yeah.
I think the hand dryer doesn't do as well.
But they're trying to...
Those have, like, so many germs in them.
That's true.
And then, like...
He's pregnant.
Our brother.
Congratulations, brother.
Brother.
The bullet was actually a baby.
Baby.
Ty.
You're gonna be a mother.
The first ever throat birth.
You don't have to care, Paul.
You cough like a child.
I just noticed this room is, like, in the middle.
So no matter what we do...
Oh, yeah.
No matter what.
We have to run over there.
301.
Yay!
I can't believe this is actually 666.
But it's really, like...
Oh, my God, brother.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know how they're scared of me.
It's really, like...
It's, like, 16 floor is each.
I think it's 15, technically, cuz the first...
Oh!
I see the anomaly...
What the fuck?
They're babies!
Is this what?
The third baby.
It's the third baby.
Oh, my God!
It's triplets!
It's actually...
Oh, my God.
You're already at the elevator.
Yeah.
Because we saw the baby.
I'm not ready for this.
Dude, you're not ready to be an uncle?
One for each of us.
I'm not ready to be a mom.
We're uncles now!
We're uncles!
Brother.
I can't believe it!
Congratulations, brother!
It's like how triplets are predisposed to...
Wait, what was that?
You heard that?
Did you hear that?
Yeah.
It was like a...
Check behind.
What do you mean check?
I'll go right side.
Okay, and also go the left side.
What do you mean also?
I chose my curtain.
It's your turn.
Rock, paper, scissors.
Rock, paper...
Okay.
Go check.
Oh, I heard it again.
I think it is in there.
Okay, I got an idea.
I was gonna jump over here and look over the curtain.
Together.
We're all we had.
This is for you, brother.
I think it's saying here.
Oh, it's like...
Okay, I'm curious.
There's nothing here.
Wait, what?
Oh.
It's just going...
Okay, alright, so we're fine.
But that has to be anomaly, right?
Yeah, that's an anomaly.
Someone said look up.
Okay, they all always say look up.
There's nothing up.
Is it on the computer?
Oh, I heard another noise too.
I think it's just the same thing.
You're just projecting.
Hey, Dev.
If you need anybody to make noises for you.
Thank you for the rain.
I didn't catch who it was.
Thank you.
Alright, where do we go?
Thank you so much.
I don't think I see anything.
I'm checking my...
You looked for two seconds.
Oh, wait.
Was this computer always on?
Oh, I see something.
Oh.
Wow.
It's kind of... that's a cool effect.
That's cool.
That's actually a cool effect.
Whoa, look at all these eyes.
Oh, they blink.
They gave me goosebumps.
They were blinking.
I'm having trypophobia.
Trypophobia warming?
Alright.
304!
Please.
Yeah, go ahead.
Go ahead.
I'll go right.
I'll go right side.
Nothing on the right.
Nothing here.
Oh wait, I have an anomaly.
What's the anomaly?
They're playing... it's like that...
Oh, they're playing...
Maze Escape game.
Yeah, they're playing this game!
Wait, is it going to...
They're going to show us...
It's going to the room.
That's our room.
Wait, uh oh.
I don't want to see that.
Wait, are they out here?
You think there's someone out here?
No, they're in our room now.
They're looking at the anomalies.
Oh, and it stopped.
The game stopped.
Oh, okay.
They're not as gamers as us.
Yeah, they got too scared and stopped playing the game.
We're never scared.
We made it to 305.
We are the first YouTubers to make it to 305.
Are we actually?
What do you think?
Don't lie on the internet, doggie.
Don't.
Here, I'll go right.
Okay, I'll go left.
Nope, no anomalies.
Anomaly.
There's an anomaly on the computer.
What is it this time?
Oh, hey!
There's like, um...
Insert your OC.
What are you talking about?
That could be you.
Those drawings where you buy art and insert your character here.
And the black screen is like the character.
What?
Did we see the same thing?
Yeah, I saw it!
There was like a black character outlining there.
It's a silhouette!
Why see each?
Your character here!
I didn't see that at all!
What did you see?
I think you need to take your mask off.
What?
No, I think you need to...
My chest saw the same thing!
What do you think?
Okay, I'll go left.
No anomalies here.
Unless you don't...
Yeah, what the hell is dopey cooking?
I don't know, man.
She's overcooking.
Oh, you don't trust me.
You're looking at the left side because you didn't even trust me.
Okay, well look at the right side.
I think we should both double check our answers.
Wait, was the needle always this huge?
What needle?
I don't think there's ever been a needle.
Oh, wait!
Was there always been like the disease...
History?
Yeah, with the...
Wait, maybe we should pay attention to this table.
Yeah, maybe.
Yeah, I feel like we should.
Wait, has there always been a history?
Has that always been... The history?
History?
Okay, it's always been here.
Okay.
Okay, it's just...
Is brother okay?
This doctor is just illiterate.
I think we're good.
I think we're good too.
Yeah.
History.
See, my chat said it was always there.
Someone said the plant.
What do you mean the plant?
The plant?
No, the plant has always been that green.
307!
Yeah!
Bing!
I hate it when it like pauses after a while.
I know, right?
Cause it's just like, what do you mean?
It's Bing, right?
Brother?
Right side?
Right side, safe.
Safe.
Left side?
History?
History.
Floor, nothing.
Ceiling, nothing.
Brother?
Exit.
Water.
Brother?
Not pregnant anymore.
Oh!
He has had the babies.
He's had the babies.
It was... it wasn't a bullet all along.
It was like an egg.
You are king.
What happened to the baby?
They're in the... yeah, they're in the baby ward.
The baby ward?
Yeah!
The ward for all you guys.
Yeah.
Alright.
It's time.
Brother?
Still the same.
Um... Help me.
Help me, help me.
Help, I'm going to drown.
I'm going to die.
I'm going to drown.
No worries, it's going to open.
The door's going to open.
I'm going to drown, I'm going to die.
The door is going to open.
Don't worry.
It's going to open.
It's going to open right now.
I'm going to die, I'm going to die.
We're gonna die!
You're doing great sweetie!
See, I told you.
She's such an overreactor.
Those were all my WISPs tears when I don't start the stream.
She hates us!
Man, what an overreaction.
Seeing that she was gonna die.
You know what, I get those anomalies a lot.
I think it's because I'm not a big ass baby.
That is not true!
Look at this!
Wait, has this always been white?
The floor?
It looks whiter than usual.
Yeah, it looks like extra bright.
Oh, um...
You might wanna get out of there.
What?
What did you see?
Wait, what did you see?
Go back in!
You have to go back in until you find the anomaly.
No, no, no, I already found it.
You go in, you go in.
It's the floor!
Oh!
We both have to restart the game!
I'm gonna get crushed!
So I think the reason why it was whiter was because the ceiling was reflecting.
The ceiling was closing in.
It was getting brighter.
The light was getting closer to the floor.
We managed to avoid drowning.
Okay.
And getting crushed.
Okay, I went in first already.
So it's your turn.
Okay, now it's my turn to go in first.
Brother, safe.
Brother.
Computer, safe.
Left side, safe.
Left side, history-m.
Safe.
History-m.
Lights, not crushing us.
Sink, dijobu.
Blow dryer, still unhygienic.
Filled with germs.
I think... I think we're safe.
Brother, give us a thumbs up if we're safe.
And before they insert like one anomaly outside just to fuck with us.
I know, right?
I feel like we should still be checking.
But they didn't last time, so...
Alright.
This is it.
Okay.
Alright.
311!
11!
Yeah!
How are hand dryers unhygienic?
Well, if they're in a bathroom...
Oh, you go in first this time.
Alright.
If they're in a bathroom, they just...
You just blow all the germs onto your hands.
Right side, nothing.
Left side, safe.
History-m.
PC.
Ground, nothing.
Brother, still there.
Brother, nothing in his brain.
Nothing going on in there.
Brother's going through it.
Wow.
There's no way there's not an anomaly.
There's no anomaly still?
Yeah, the poopy air gets blown around.
It's disgusting.
It's like when you're...
It's like you have to change your toothbrush every couple of months.
Yeah.
Because like...
Yeah, every couple of months you have to change your toothbrush.
I thought it was more frequent than that.
Wait, how frequent?
Wait a minute.
How frequent is it supposed to be?
Someone said...
I thought it was like every month or so.
Someone said three months max.
Okay.
I was like, wait you change your toothbrush every month?
Well, like I've been getting sick a lot.
How many months?
So I've been changing it a lot recently.
Oh, okay.
Not every year?
Not every three to four years?
Alright, Chai, let me...
It's like a mattress.
You're just supposed to flip it upside down.
You're not supposed to get a new mattress.
You just flip it.
Okay, for those who don't know why I had to change my toothbrush every couple of months.
It's because like you know how you're using your bathroom and you're flushing?
Yeah.
If it's all in the same room, you're gonna wanna change...
Wait.
Oh!
Is that alive?
Hey, hey.
Oh, it's a cat!
There's one next to you!
Oh, look!
Wait, what is happening?
Oh my god, he's dying.
There's another one!
There's another one over here!
There's a creature in the universe!
There's one under the couch too!
Wait, they're all just dying!
What's going on?
Dyes of cringe.
They see us and they're like, no documentary here.
They haven't changed their toothbrush yet.
So yeah, you have to change your toothbrush every couple of months because when you're flushing, you know, stuff goes out.
You're ingesting that, man.
That's why you close your mouth.
Do you open your mouth?
What do you mean?
When I brush my teeth, how else do you brush your teeth?
Oh, okay.
I thought like, you know, when you're flushing, you like, mouth open and like, ah.
No, I just mouth open over the seat, you know?
That's why you gotta change your toothbrush.
Six!
Where's the other six?
Where's the third six?
You found it?
Six is here.
It's over there.
Six, six, six.
We're gonna make it!
Someone's like, wait, you changed your toothbrush?
Oh no.
You don't change your toothbrush until the bristles are all frayed?
What do you mean?
That's why I don't flush.
No!
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, brother is huge.
Brother is hitting the gym.
Bro, I love how we could tell immediately.
Yeah.
Brother, we're supposed to be the same size.
Brother, you can't drink more milk than us.
Yeah, how can we?
Yo, he's been doing too much protein shakes.
Brother, you've been going to the gym without us?
It's not fair.
Brother is going to join basketball.
He's on the hospital basketball team.
Oh shit, we're almost to 16.
We're at almost 16.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
He's big.
Okay.
Alright.
Brother's the same height.
Oh, yeah.
No.
Oh, what the hell is that?
I think it's following you.
Does it rush over?
Oh, wait, what is going on?
Oh.
Wait, will it stab us?
I can't.
Oh, they're growing bigger.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait, it's cheesy.
I think it's babies.
Galacka.
It's protecting the babies.
It's like those, those like, those like bears.
That was the brother.
Yeah.
Alright, last floor.
Last floor, baby.
Until we're at 400.
400.
All we have to do is, the ones we're at 400...
Oh, yeah, definitely.
What do you think is over there?
Let's look.
What is it?
Oh.
I don't want to die though.
Let's go closer.
No, there was nothing behind it.
Did you really check?
Did you actually check?
You don't trust me?
I trust you.
I just wanted to be sure if you checked.
You don't trust me.
You always look at what the stuff is.
I don't know what the stuff I looked at.
I hope you don't die this time again.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry for sacrificing my life for you.
Wait, what's in here?
I don't know.
I just saw like PC monitors in the toilet.
Wait.
Oh, we have to open the doors.
Oh.
Uh oh.
Ah!
What the fuck?
That was your door!
Wait, but we just restart.
It's fine.
Uh oh.
Sorry.
Just run away!
What do you mean?
Oh, Skippity.
Hey, Skippity!
Oh, you missed it.
This one is empty though.
I can't believe it.
The boomer missed it.
Oh, it's flooding.
It's flooding.
Was that you?
No, that was not me.
I did not open.
Why does all the doors you opened end up killing us?
It's not me!
What do you mean it's not you?
You lit every door you opened killing us.
I am!
Oh, who's laughing?
Oh my god, it's not going inside the...
Oh no.
We're gonna drown!
My toilet's laughing at me.
My toilet's laughing at me too!
Oh, I found it!
I found it!
Where, where, where?
Where are you?
Go in!
Hurry up!
Oh shit.
Oh, I got in.
Hurry up.
You don't even say where we're at.
You say hurry up.
Thanks for the instructions there, man.
Wait, is this the same room?
Oh no, we're in the toilet now.
Oh, it's a different...
Oh, toilet.
Whoa, brother.
Our brother needs privacy.
Brother!
Oh, he's us!
We're gonna have to check inside every single...
I don't think so.
Oh yeah, we have to look through the crevice.
Oh my god, look at us!
It's us!
Family portrait!
Look at family photo in the bathroom, everybody!
Meet and greet in the bathroom!
Six toilets?
There's six of everything.
There's even six sinks!
Oh my god, and there's six blow dryers!
Right next to the toilet.
They're gonna blow that into your hand.
Brother, do you have enough toilet paper?
I like how the kids sink is next to the urinal.
Okay, this one's gotta be easy.
There's like nothing in here, right guys?
Yeah, it has to be.
We can speed run this to 600.
We can speed run this.
We're literally so close to the end.
200 more floors.
We're like masters now.
Oh my god.
We're the masters of the universe.
I don't know about that.
What do you mean?
The mirror will be fun?
Don't say that.
How would you know?
Check the mirror.
There's blood!
There's more than just blood!
Those hands are coming out of the wall.
It's like a PNG.
He's holding a PNG of the airmen.
They're supposed to be like behind the vent.
Wait, does that mean vents are fake?
Like they don't lead anyone?
There's no ventilation?
There's no ventilation in the bathroom?
That's not hygienic at all.
Alright.
I like how we don't say anything.
We just turn around.
Just 180.
I was like, alright, that's it.
That's an anomaly, right?
Doki, I have to pee.
Don't worry, I'll do this for us.
Don't die in there.
Just stay there.
What if I just die?
Don't die!
Why are you still here?
Okay, I'll be right back.
Hold on, guys.
We're just waiting to see if I get it.
Oh, okay.
There was no anomalies.
Has there always been three trash cans down here?
Why is there trash cans?
I didn't look down, guys.
I didn't...
Guys!
Has there always been three trash cans?
I didn't look down!
Yeah?
Why would the trash cans be here?
Okay, there's always been three trash...
Two, four...
No, we have to start counting!
Two, four, six...
Two, four...
Wait, where's five?
Two, four, six...
Okay.
Two...
Four, five...
Where's the six?
There's the six broom!
Two...
Two, four, six...
Two, four...
Where's the six trash can?
Six!
Okay.
There's six of everything.
Two, four, five...
Wait, there's five...
Oh, six.
That's a...
Okay.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
I think we did it.
No anomalies.
If we get it wrong, I blame chat.
There's a seven urinal?
I don't know...
There's six urinals.
Someone can't even count.
Alright.
I think we're good.
I think there's no anomalies.
Wow.
Min is so slow.
Of course she goes to the bathroom when there's no anomalies.
Look at her.
Was there...
Yes, there was six toilets.
Because the whole game is based off of six, six, six.
So there's six of everything.
Hold on.
I gotta get tea.
Min, don't come over here!
There's no anomalies!
Get over here!
No!
You can't just...
What do you mean you have to get...
tea!
There's no anomalies!
If only I could just leave.
Oh my god.
Oh I can push her to the right!
Why didn't you guys say that earlier?
Oh my god.
I could've just pushed her.
I can't believe it.
I could've done that in the very beginning.
I messed up.
Wait, no?
Okay.
There we go.
Alright.
We're getting you to the other side!
Nice.
We did it.
We're professionals.
Okay, I gotta like...
make sure...
In case there is...
an anomaly...
Or there's no anomaly as well.
Okay, no.
Alright.
Here we go.
I'm gaming.
Alright.
Everything looks the same.
I'm back.
Oh my god.
You scared the shit out of me.
I had to push you to the other side of the elevator.
I guess there was...
Everything looks good?
There was no anomaly.
You have plenty of time.
I'm gonna check.
What do you mean?
We're on the other floor now?
Oh, nope.
What do you mean?
Oh, let me double check.
This is a new floor.
Come on.
Let's hurry it up.
I literally pushed you from one elevator to the next.
Alright.
Here we go.
405.
Was she brave, you guys?
Be honest.
I was so brave.
I counted.
I learned how to count today.
Really?
I learned my ABCs.
You took your counting medicine.
Yeah, I took my counting medicine.
I just realized we have to count these items as well.
Because like...
How many trash cans?
Six.
Six?
Okay.
Yeah, it's 666.
Oh, it's 7.
No, there's 7.
2, 4, 6.
What do you mean?
You're 6.
Someone did learn to count.
I didn't learn how to count.
It's me.
Someone didn't learn.
2, 4, 6.
I think we're good.
I think we're good too.
I'm pretty sure.
I think so.
Back to kindergarten.
Min didn't take her counting medicine.
That's okay.
Send me back to kindergarten.
Let me be a child again.
Alright.
Yay!
4, 0, 6!
That's pretty impressive you were able to punch me all the way.
I'm trying to make sure...
God.
What was that?
It was that blow dryer.
Oh my god.
The blow dryer.
That scared me so bad I couldn't even make a noise.
It's just like, Whoa, shit!
I thought it was something chasing us.
We talked too much shit about the blow dryers, guys.
Okay.
Alright, we're still normal.
2, 4 Let's test our counting.
2, 4, 6.
Oh,
we have to make sure to look between the toilets too.
Why is this toilet filled with...
Was there always a toilet in here?
Yeah, isn't this the handicap slot too?
Yeah, because it's a bigger stall.
That's so messed up.
They did not care.
This is a hospital!
There's so many people in wheelchairs!
And yet they filled it up!
2, 4, 6.
I'm looking up.
I mean, we counted everything.
There's 6 lights.
2, 4... Wait, no, there's 8 lights.
Has there always been 8 lights?
I don't think it's that meticulous, right?
I don't think so either.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a bloody handprint?
What do you mean bloody handprint?
Everybody's spamming handprint.
Handprint?
Is it in the toilet maybe?
Did anyone spam handprint on your chat?
There are 4 lights.
What do you mean?
There's 4 lights?
Handprint by the kid's urinal.
There's a kid's urinal?
I don't think there is.
They're just saying that the fuck with us.
Oh!
That's not a urinal!
That's a snake!
Wait, there's also like a hand down there.
Yeah, there's something in the trash can.
Wow, that's sneaky.
Oh, that was a sneaky one.
Is it a hand?
I'm trying to see it.
I think it was.
I'm pretty sure it's a hand.
We're not short enough to see it.
We're not a chat.
We now know someone in the chat pees in sinks.
Someone uses the kid's urinal to pee in the sink.
I don't think this person is allowed near the kid's hospital.
Someone's peeing in sinks over here.
In public, you're in public sinks.
What if you stand there?
I dare you to stand there.
Stand where?
Over there?
Wait, there's a shadow over there.
I triple dog dare you.
I already dared you!
It's gone.
Oh, it's gone.
Oh, it's back!
Wait, wait, wait.
Now it's your turn.
Oh, it's gone.
You like absorbed him.
Yeah, yeah, you too.
Alright, you too.
Oh, it didn't move it back any further though.
Yeah, it's just there.
Alright.
Anomaly!
We're so good at this.
I know.
We're like professional anomaly hunters.
Even, yeah, we didn't get help from chat at all.
Yeah, yeah.
We got like...
We've like never failed.
We literally have never failed.
Yeah, we've had... we've been consistent throughout this.
This game is just a really long game.
Why do you run past the door?
Why do you say...
Oh!
Brother!
Brother, it's okay!
It's a miracle!
Brother has risen.
On the fourth day he rises.
Oh my god, guys!
Metal gear rising.
Oh my god, it's a miracle, guys!
Why do you always run past... oh.
Okay, someone peed in the urinals.
Someone actually peed in the urinals.
Yeah.
They mixed the juices up.
What do you mean by that?
Only bros understand.
I don't think even bros will understand what you mean.
Only bros know.
Alright, let's see.
Hello, brother.
Don't run past.
Just run...
Just run inside.
Wait, there's something weird.
Something weird?
Look, look.
Oh!
Yeah, you see that?
The caution signs are moving.
Yeah.
Wait, they're coming.
They're coming towards us.
Wait, they're coming after us.
Wait, they're after coming after us.
Yeah.
Wait, what would the caution signs do?
Wait, let's see.
What if we die?
What if they do fucking eat us?
They're converging.
Like, what?
It's like a mating ritual.
Oh!
We're watching a mating ritual right now.
Nope.
Oh!
I don't wanna...
I told you, it does nothing.
I'm not their mate.
Come on, it was a mate.
I think they'll block the entrance.
Oh, maybe.
Yeah, I think they're gonna block the exit.
Alright, the floor is wet.
Thank you for the rain.
Oh my god.
Maria, thank you for the rain.
The floor is wet.
The floor is wet?
Yeah.
Ew.
From all the juices in the urine.
Your words, not mine.
See, I told you, you knew what it means.
I knew it.
See?
She knows what it means.
Don't run past the door.
Just go straight in.
Don't run past.
I've always...
I've always walked in.
I don't know what you're talking about.
No, you haven't.
Literally every time.
She's rewriting history right now.
No.
She's rewriting history.
Let's take a look at this to see if she's right.
Okay, here we go.
2, 4, 6.
There are 6 trash cans.
I think it's no anomaly.
I think this one's good.
I'm looking up.
Are the toilets- There's nothing in the mirror.
Are the toilets up or are they normal?
Yeah, they've always been up.
It's a men's urinal.
The urinal is different.
It's a men's bathroom.
I guess so.
The doors are cracked?
Are you okay brother?
There are no doors that are cracked.
What do you mean?
All the doors have been cracked.
Yeah.
Okay.
Someone was like, saw something.
What did you see?
Did you take your meds?
I saw something.
I saw you.
Nothing in the mirror.
There's sticks of everything.
Are you gaslighting?
No, I'm not.
Wow!
He's like peek-a-boo.
I think there's a biggie in here.
Oh no!
Donkey crash?
Oh no, I'm okay now.
I'm okay.
Oh my god.
It was so scary.
It was so scary because I said that and then everything just stopped.
Everything stopped moving and I was like, oh no.
What happened?
Wait, are there more fire things than usual?
I mean, you can literally count.
Was there always six?
There's six of everything.
Yeah, I mean, I was like, was there always six in 666?
Oh my god.
That was so spooky.
Spooky!
Her stream is alive.
My stream is alive now.
I think there's nothing here.
There's been like not a lot of anomalies for this one.
Not for this one, no.
Yeah.
I mean, it's like such an empty room.
What are you gonna do?
I think like this one's like harder to have anomalies.
I think so too.
I think we're fine.
Alright.
Oh, I can't punch you.
Haha, you hit your quota.
I'm trying.
What happened?
Why can't I punch all the time?
How come we can't have six brothers?
I don't understand.
We can only have five brothers, but it goes up to four players.
Yeah.
Where's our...
Where's brother four, five, and six?
We went in the wrong elevator.
This was you.
No, it wasn't!
You left the way!
This was you.
No, I followed you.
I followed you.
You could have stopped me.
It's okay.
We can speedrun.
You could have stopped me.
We can speedrun!
Handprint.
No.
Check if the thing appears.
Wait, but what if there's new anomalies?
What if there's new ones that we don't...
Oh, wait, no.
This is zero.
It's always zero.
Oh, this is zero.
You're right.
No!
Why didn't you stop me?
No, no.
This is Chad's fault.
They should have told us.
Instead, they laughed at our jokes because we're just so funny.
Oh my...
Okay.
Thank you, game.
Thank you.
Don't worry.
We can speedrun.
What floor are we on?
How far did we get to?
We got to 13.
We got to 13, man!
We got to 13!
Oh, oh, oh.
What the fuck?
I dare you.
I triple dog dare you.
You know what?
I'm not afraid.
Oh my god.
I killed...
You murdered them.
You didn't see anything.
You cleaned up the bodies really good.
Oh my god.
You didn't see anything.
I don't know what you're talking about.
You killed them.
No, I did not, brother.
Remember, there's always been three brothers.
Remember that.
There's always been three brothers.
There's never been a fourth, fifth, or sixth brother.
Oh, that is the mating ritual again.
Oh, it's the mating ritual.
You're right.
Here they come.
This is why there's only three brothers.
I'm an accessory to murder.
They won't believe you.
Hey, but that was a new one.
So that means...
That was a new one.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
We got this.
Speed run.
We have to be careful of the head though, peeking out.
Yeah, but the head... I mean, I'll look at it.
I'm looking at it.
Okay.
I'm looking through the cracks right now while we...
I'm looking through the cracks.
I don't see anything.
I'm peeking.
I'm voyeuring.
I'm...
I don't see anything.
Brother is still being brother.
This is why he doesn't talk.
He saw some stuff he wasn't supposed to.
He saw some stuff.
Mating ritual.
Check for handprint.
I already looked.
We all looked.
Here we go.
405.
Give it up for 405.
Bing.
Yeah.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Brother is still on the toilet.
It's so loud.
It's so damn loud.
I never expect it.
No one ever expects some low drives.
Oh gosh.
At least we got it out of the way.
Oh my god.
Here we go.
Everybody, we're okay?
We're okay!
We're almost back to 13.
Brother...
Brother is not performing any miracles right now.
I'm looking...
There's no hazard.
What?
Check the doors.
Oh.
Woah!
What the fuck?
He closed the door!
What?
How could...
Stop!
Stop looking at the...
Stop it!
Stop looking at him!
How come she lets you look but I can't?
What?
Were you invited to something?
I think so.
But that was also a new one.
That was a new one.
Yeah, that was a new one.
I've never seen that one before.
Yeah, so...
That could've been 14, 15, and 16.
Brother...
Brother is not performing miracles.
No handprint.
No peek-a-boo.
We're missing like one new anomaly.
I think so too.
Yeah.
No hands.
We can see our faces.
There's no hands coming from the vents.
I think we're fine.
No anomalies.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
See?
We're so good at this.
Let's go.
We could've been at floor 500.
Okay.
We could've been at floor...
Shut up.
We'll be there.
We could've been at floor 500.
We could've been there!
We'll be there!
We'll get there!
Okay.
Brother?
Brother sitting down.
Faces?
Handprint!
All right, back to the elevator.
Back to the elevator.
Bro, we got a routine going on now.
We have a system!
I know!
We're Speedrunners!
We're Speedrunners.
Speedrun.com!
Sign us up!
Speakrun.com.
Why are we speedrunning?
Because we...
No, no, because you...
Chat messed up.
Brothers, brothering.
We have faces.
There's no shadow footprint.
Oh, there's the peek-a-boo!
Peek-a-boo!
Alright.
But not you, Dragoon.
It's not your chat.
This is the slowest speedrun.
What do you mean?
Dragoon, I don't mean you.
What chat are we talking about?
What are you trying to apply?
I think there's only two chats here.
Oh, brother is...
Brother comes after us.
Brother runs!
Brother walks here.
Oh my god, a miracle!
The second miracle!
What if he came to the door?
What if he was just like... He was trying to talk to us.
He was trying to communicate.
He was like, brothers...
Brothers, please, this is the worst time.
I'm sentient.
Brothers, I have something very important to tell you.
Oh, it's the footprints.
Alright.
This is the one time I can say whatever it is.
I've been keeping it in this entire time.
Oh my god, we're almost there.
Back to work.
We're still missing one more anomaly that we haven't seen before.
Because we got...
Because we were missing three and now we saw two of the new ones.
Yeah.
We need the... We're missing the...
This one's gonna be the faces.
Nope, nevermind.
Nope.
No urinals.
I don't see anything.
There's no hands coming out of the vents.
Nothing.
At least they don't make us count these.
Thank god.
I know.
I'm not paying attention.
I know it's all sixes, but I'm not paying attention.
Me neither.
Alright.
Okay, let's go.
4-13!
Back where we started!
Yeah, you're right.
What's it saying?
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
What's this one?
No faces.
No blood in the urinals.
No hands coming out.
Uh...
There's nothing.
Another... No anomaly?
Two in a row?
Two, four, six...
Come on, ghosts!
You're getting...
Come on!
You're getting a little lazy right now.
Lazy!
Yeah!
Come on!
Okay, whatever.
What is this?
We want an actual challenge.
This way?
This way, this way.
4-14!
The last three has to be the anomalies ones.
Because we're missing the faces, the hands coming out of the vent, and the blood in the urinals.
And the blood... Yeah, we're missing those three.
Okay, so, easy peasy.
We got this, guys.
Alright, which one is this?
Hands!
Alright.
You know what?
We can...
I bet you, you won't risk it.
We stay in the...
elevator for the last three.
Stay in the elevator?
Oh, me?
No, no, no.
We press the buttons.
We don't even have to look at it.
Because the last two has to be anomalies.
You're a coward.
What do you mean I'm a coward?
I wanted to go into the room!
You're a coward.
You know it's an anomaly!
You even knew it!
Blood in the urinal.
I knew it.
The last one...
has to be the mirrors.
Okay, then you can check.
Alright.
No, I don't even need to check.
I'm gonna press the button.
It's too risky!
I'm gonna do it.
How much you wanna bet?
I will bet money.
I will bet an Akasupa.
Yo, you know I'm right!
You know I'm right!
You don't wanna bet!
You're wrong.
Why are you running back this way?
Why?
You're wrong.
That's why I'm smarty!
I'm gonna die immediately on this one.
So that...
Where are we?
Oh my god.
60 seconds in heaven.
Why is it so dark in there?
Oh no.
We gotta go downstairs.
I think we broke her ankles.
Maybe we don't push each other then.
Maybe we can't actually.
You can't run?
You can't even run?
I fucking ran and I broke my ankle.
There's something like humming.
I like ran and I broke my ankle.
What happened?
You are weak bones.
What happened to you?
I was spraying with glass bones.
Oh my god.
Please.
God no.
Are you even watching?
Can you see what's happening?
I was pouring with glass bones.
There's a girl whispering.
Every breath I take...
is pain.
Shut up.
You weak willed woman.
Oh my god.
I'm so close.
I have bone-a-titis.
Do I just walk?
Oh my god.
Wait.
There's a face there.
There's a face?
Where?
Look at it.
It would be so funny if you look at it again.
Look at your face you liar.
Yes there is.
Why am I the only one that survives these?
I'm sorry my bones were made of glass.
You're gonna fucking bring up my medical history.
Your brother has been demoted to being a janitor.
He's a janitor.
This is always in here.
This little head bag.
They're throwing away body parts.
Oh yeah.
This little head bag.
Why are you throwing away body parts?
Okay I don't think...
There's so many caution wet.
Six brooms.
Six trash cans.
But there's only five sinks.
Oh I feel like that's gonna be an anomaly.
They're just gonna bring a six sink out of nowhere.
And there's five trash cans.
There's five trash cans?
Oh cause this is like floor 500.
We're so close.
Man.
We have 266 floors to go.
We're almost at the finish line.
I did not expect that.
I didn't expect this game to be like three hours long.
I didn't expect that.
Well you know if some...
chatters wouldn't...
you know... give us the wrong information.
Oh you're so right.
If some chatters didn't...
backseat us better.
Oh.
Oh god that actually...
That actually got me.
Wait.
That's the anomaly right?
It started us over.
No it's 501.
That's where we were at.
Yeah so we go up.
That was the anomaly.
Oh okay then go up.
Yeah.
That had to be.
That.
That kinda got me.
I was like I just got a new PC last week.
Like what do you mean?
What do you mean?
And I saw 666.
Yeah you guys it's the dragoons.
It's not you.
Yeah you guys it's the wiz.
Don't worry.
It's always the wiz.
Go into the rooms.
Oh good.
Good.
It's both of us.
Oh.
Brother help us.
Brother.
Brother protect us brother.
Brother please.
Go big.
Go.
Yeah.
It's Johnny.
Is he gonna break it down?
Johnny.
Okay that was good.
It's Johnny.
Yo that was so good.
That was good.
I like that.
It was the perfectly cut rectangle in the door.
Yeah.
Blender rectangle.
Delete.
Alright here we go.
Let's go.
I wonder what it would have looked like on the outside.
I know right.
I am pretty curious.
That was a good one.
You know what Tess you got that.
You can have that one.
I don't think there's anything here.
I don't see any anomalies.
The bags all have one.
Check the signs if they say any other 666.
Oh yeah.
I feel like every floor has a 666 somewhere.
They do.
Sometimes.
Some place.
Somewhere.
666.
Have you been counting all of these?
They're all 5 right?
All 5.
They're all 5.
The 5th floor.
Or the 500th floor.
The dev is so funny.
Alright here we go.
Johnny goes in the square hole.
The Johnny goes.
Goes in the square hole.
Go on in.
Alright.
There's gotta be something in here.
Caution.
Nothing.
Nothing in the bag.
Is there always something in...
There's no 6's anywhere.
6's would be like in the trash can.
Something.
Yeah.
Like at the bottom of the trash can.
Somewhere.
I don't see any body parts coming out.
I think we're good.
I'm going on the other side.
Okay.
We're good.
Goodbye brother.
Where are you?
Oh.
You don't.
You never trust me.
You don't believe.
Even though I was right.
I was like the last 3 floors.
If we go to 500 I'm just saying.
The last 3 floors were anomalies.
And you didn't trust me.
You were like no.
You wouldn't even bet real money into it.
Cause you knew I was right.
You knew I was right.
I was just being cautious.
You know your head bobbles up and down when you run.
Like actual running.
Wait.
Something seems different.
No.
That's way too many.
Many plugs.
Right?
Yes.
Way.
I thought it was a plug.
I think that's way too many.
Oh.
There's 6 of everything.
There's 6 of everything suddenly.
Oh my god.
We returned to 4.
You're right.
There's 6 of everything.
I like how you were like.
Look at the plugs.
I'm like looking at that.
Look at everything else.
Very prepared.
You focused on the fucking plugs.
I mean.
It's the first thing I saw.
I don't know.
I'm like.
I got the giant red fire hydrant.
It was just so many plugs.
Look.
They were covering the wall was the first thing I saw.
Oh.
There's a baby.
There is a.
I'm dead.
I'm spectating.
The baby kills me.
Babies are dangerous.
Don't look at the baby.
The baby!
Don't look at the baby!
And you were judging me when I killed those two girls!
The baby killed me!
It should have killed you!
I was protecting you, brother!
Oh, brother's about to explode?
Oh my god, brother's a TNT?
No!
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Goodbye, brother.
He was a brother to me.
Brother was literally...
You know that meme of the guy sitting and he's like super bright?
That's why he's sitting in the little express drive?
Come inside!
What is wrong with you?
I was waiting for you to be inside first!
I was already inside!
No, you were not!
No, no, no.
Check my vibe!
Time stampers!
I don't think there's anomalies here.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
Wait, only four mobs?
I don't think the chat's fucking with us.
Nooooooo.
Five-oh-nine!
I knew it!
I knew that chat.
That was way too detailed.
Because a real chatter would be like...
Oh!
The head is moved.
You sure?
Yeah.
It's not moving now.
No, like they're in different positions.
Oh!
Are you sure?
Oh, you're right.
It's moved up closer.
You're right.
I see it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Chat, I know when you're lying because...
I'm so good.
I like find everything so quickly before Doki.
I'm sure.
Yeah, yeah, like the six plugs that you saw too.
And there were actually six plugs!
I don't know why that's what you're so focused on.
WOOOOOO!
That's a lot of...
That was not six boxes.
How do we get out?
The collision!
I'll pinch you out!
I'm gonna punch you out!
I can't get out!
I'm trying to push through the wall!
I can't!
Push me!
No, I'm trying!
No, you're not doing anything!
What do you mean?
See, this is why we...
I got out!
Come on!
Oh, it disappeared.
Okay.
Wow!
You didn't even try!
See, this is why only one of us needed to go inside.
Oh my god!
If it was just one of us inside, we would not have to...
You still would have needed me!
Okay, you can go then this time.
I'm drinking my tea.
Hold on.
Okay, you're drinking your tea.
I see.
I don't think there's anything here.
What are you laughing at?
I'm serious!
There's nothing here!
It's because you walk in for two seconds and you're like, Nothing here!
Because I have good memory!
Unlike somebody.
Who has gotten... Okay, I actually need chat to keep track of who has gotten the most things in this game.
Yeah, and they'll say me!
Wait, was there a mirror in that game?
There was a mirror in there!
I got gaslit.
Look, I'm gonna say...
You know when they're lying?
When they get extra detailed.
Because usually when they think they see an anomaly, they'll be like, mirror.
But then they said, face in the mirror.
I got one guide for real.
You got one guide.
Five!
Twelve!
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
I hope it's no anomalies.
Guys, there's no way Doki would have gotten through this game without me.
Guys, I was so good at Exit 8.
Okay.
I literally had a speedrun.
This is literally Exit 8, but multiplayer.
So I did that solo.
It's a different game.
This is literally Exit 8.
Oh, anomaly.
See, I found it before you.
I found it before you.
Look at that.
I didn't even see it.
If I said nothing and let you pick the pathway...
That was actually really good.
I'll give you that one.
You don't have to press the button though.
Which means I found it.
Wow!
What are these new rules?
She's definitely in kindergarten where they invent new rules just so they can win.
Yeah, you were blocking my view actually.
So I just couldn't see it because your pig head was in the way.
You didn't win.
I don't think there's anything.
I don't think so either.
No anomaly.
Yeah?
You don't believe me?
I'm just checking.
Oh, someone doesn't believe me.
Oh, you pressed the button?
Okay.
This is your choice for no anomaly.
5, 4...
Oh!
You said it first.
Remember your rule.
Your fucking rule.
It means that you found the anomaly.
I don't think there's anything here.
Do you know why we messed up?
We went to the wrong elevator.
We went to the orange light.
No, we didn't.
No, we went to the other one, right?
No, we went back.
How does this happen?
That's what I'm telling you.
And the rules are too confusing for this game.
There's two rules.
The orange light needs to be more obvious.
What?
There's two rules.
It needs to be more obvious.
I'm telling you.
How much more obvious do they need to be?
The orange light needs to be like so bright.
They need signs.
They need signs where it just has like big like 50 font text.
It says you came here.
Impact font.
Anomaly here.
No anomaly here.
It's the bag heads.
I found it.
Yeah, put the...
The one we fucked up it was you who fucked up.
Not me.
Someone should stay outside for Johnny.
You're right.
Alright, I'll be outside.
I wanna see Johnny.
Rock, paper, scissors.
I think there's no anomaly here.
There's no anomaly.
Don't go that way.
I was just testing to see if it's like three in a row.
I can't believe we got... we were so close.
We were at 540.
We were so close.
It's the fifth floor.
This is why this game is gonna take us three plus hours.
This is why.
I don't think there's an anomaly.
Johnny, Johnny.
You gotta wait for me.
No.
I was able to get out.
You can too.
Come on.
Push the boxes.
Go outside and push the boxes inwards.
I pushed them outwards.
You can do it too.
Come on.
Just use your legs.
What do you mean I'm using... I'm too tall.
I'm sorry for being six foot seven.
Says on my Tinder profile.
Six foot seven.
Well, I'm gonna wait in the elevator for your lazy ass.
Okay, it's gone.
Alright, here I am.
Oh my god.
I'm getting there.
I'm going as fast as my six foot seven legs start taking me.
You have really short legs.
You have the widest torso in history.
Five.
Oh, fuck.
Eight more to go.
Why is it always on thirteen that we mess up?
I know.
I mean, thirteen is an unlucky number.
It's a TNT brother.
It's TNT brother.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Please, brother.
Think of your children.
Oh.
Alright, here we go.
We went to the correct elevator.
Is he a creeper?
Yeah, he's a creeper.
Don't call our brother a creep.
What's wrong with you?
Oh my god, what are you talking about?
He has children.
That doesn't make him a creep at all.
That makes him...
Alright, I don't think there's any anomaly here.
I don't think so either.
There's no smileys.
Unless there's a new one.
Oh, that's true.
We didn't...
Think of new ones.
I think in general it doesn't.
There's no anomalies.
Wait, wait, wait.
Anomaly.
Oh, anomaly!
The six, six, six.
I knew it.
I knew the six would come back.
See?
Guys, remember the competition that Mint proposed?
Where whoever catches the most anomalies wins?
What?
What competition?
I just said who has the most.
This competition that Mint really wanted to do.
Where she was like, Oh guys, time's up.
Every time, like, whoever picks the...
Okay.
Okay, but I'm still winning.
Sure.
In your dreams, I guess.
I like how you don't even walk inside.
No, because we wanted to see Johnny.
Oh yeah.
Remember?
How could you forget about Johnny?
He's been there for us.
Yes, Papa.
I don't think there's anomalies.
I don't think so either.
Alright, here we go.
Yay!
Finally the closer one.
Every time there's like, ba-dum.
I feel like we're gonna get in there.
Wait, people are saying... Oh, we missed it.
Wait, what was there?
Huh?
Oh.
That was you.
You called it.
No, I didn't!
That was you.
You called it.
We're gonna be stuck at 4,500 forever!
The door was backwards?
Wait, how... What do you mean the door was... How can a door be back?
Backwards!
Okay, this is the normal one, remember?
Oh yeah, this is the... Yeah, that's right.
We're gonna be stuck at floor 500!
I could tell you were hydrating before the cry.
Oh, it's on the wrong hinges.
Oh my god, so that's something else we have to...
We have to keep track of the wrong hinges?
So right now... Oh no.
Yeah, right now.
Oh, it's backwards.
It's backwards.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh good, we got it out of the way.
Yeah, we got that out of the way.
That is such a sneaky one.
That should have been a floor 516 one right there.
Not stupid!
People miss that too!
Yeah, everyone has probably missed that in their lives.
Yeah, everybody.
Those who called it out has played this game before.
I could tell.
Johnny?
Yes, Papa?
Oh, it's all the plugs.
All the plugs?
Oh yeah, it's the...
All the plugs.
We're stuck in 500 forever.
We'll never get to 666.
He was right!
The dev was right!
We will never get to 666!
We'll never get to 666!
We're stuck here forever!
It's Chad's fault.
They warned us soon enough.
They could have yelled at us.
They really could have.
They could have screamed if they knew it instantly.
I was gonna say, I was gonna say, I was gonna say, I was gonna say, I was gonna say, Come on!
Come on, Min!
Get over here!
I'm coming!
Don't push me back any further!
Oh, look at me!
I actually got out, so it was clearly just a skill issue for you.
Oh yeah, it's not like I helped you get there.
Look out!
You punched me out!
I don't know what you're talking about.
I helped you get there.
Guys, guys, if you guys see any anomalies, make sure to...
We will totally see.
We will see it.
And we won't miss it at all.
Yeah.
There's no sixes.
I think there's no anomalies.
Guys, this is your chance right now.
We're saying there's no anomalies.
This is your chance.
I'm gonna look at everything really slowly.
We're gonna look at this really slowly.
No anomalies.
If there was an anomaly, it's not our fault.
We gave you a chance.
No help.
Alright, here we go.
Up we go.
Bing!
505!
Johnny?
What if we both have to be inside though?
No, I don't think so.
Because what if it's a solo?
Single player?
A single player, it wouldn't matter.
Yeah, because they would be inside.
No, wait, what?
Oh yeah!
Okay, okay.
No anomalies.
No, we have to go to the further one.
No!
Maybe it'll give us back to back no anomalies.
She's an actual bird.
What does that say about you, huh?
You messed up too.
You have no excuse for messing up.
Not as much as you.
At least people can say I'm a bird brain.
What about you then?
I'm dead.
I have like...
My brain is ectoplasm.
Your brain is...
It's literal mush, okay?
Oh, smileys.
Smileys, okay.
Back to the long one we go.
Don't worry, I'll speed you up.
I'm gonna speed you up.
Actually, you're really not doing anything.
It's like I'm getting a massage.
I'm a chiropractor, not licensed.
Alright.
Next one.
Guys, we're so close to 513 again.
We're gonna make it.
Are we that close?
I don't know.
Oh, the trash bags.
It's the bags.
At least the shoes running is kind of ASMR.
Yeah, it is.
You know, when it says hospital 666, I honestly thought the 6 was a joke.
Wait, so do we get to like...
What happens?
Do we get to just floor 6?
No, it's 666.
So it could be like 613.
616, 615.
And then all the way to 666 at the end.
Okay.
Alright.
Johnny.
No Johnny.
Oh, it's the 666.
Back to the long hallway we go.
You didn't even go into the room.
Cause we're gonna see the Johnny.
What do you mean?
Yeah, but what if you have to come inside?
What if we have to go inside?
I would have gone inside.
To see if we triggered the Johnny.
The Johnny.
That Johnny.
That silly guy.
I know.
I wanna see him too though.
Alright, I'll go inside.
We'll do Russian Roulette again.
Alright, one of us has to get the baby.
And the other one gets Johnny.
It pushed me inside!
It pushed you inside!
We get the POV of Johnny again!
Front row seats!
I'm gonna get really close to him.
Yeah, Johnny.
We wanna see you.
We wanna see your face.
Wow!
There's Johnny.
There he is.
I like how it grew a little.
Sounds like Freddy Fazbear.
There's Johnny.
Someone asked to sit with me.
And said I see an anomaly.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
I never would have gotten...
Brothers on fire.
Why is it always the long one with brothers on fire?
I don't know.
This game is breaking us.
We didn't think...
We didn't realize when they said 666.
It was literally 666.
6 hours.
Remember when we said 24 hour stream?
We were not joking.
We meant it.
Oh, it's the baby.
It's the killer baby.
I went the wrong way.
Push me faster.
The baby.
I think we didn't look at the baby.
So the baby's not coming.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's good.
Stupid baby.
That's why you're a baby.
You should have died by the baby.
Why was I supposed to die by the baby?
Because I died from the baby last time.
Yeah, but you're stupid.
Yeah, because totally I knew that looking at a baby would kill me.
I told you I'm not ready to be a mother.
I saw that Tokyo Jungle play through.
You were so ready to be a mother.
You should play that game.
You should build...
You told me that I killed your little birdies.
Was there anomaly?
Anomalies?
Yes.
Why are you just standing back there?
Because there was no anomaly.
What are you doing?
Oh my god.
I almost did it.
What are you doing?
There was no Akasupa.
So she couldn't tell, guys.
I know, you guys.
I was the Akasupa, but I did it for free.
The way you were standing there...
It was so menacing.
What haven't we gotten?
I was like, what is she doing?
No way.
There has to be an anomaly in here.
There's no anomaly.
Guys, we're waiting for the Akasupa right now.
Wait, there's something on the floor.
Is it?
Yeah, it's a face on the floor.
Oh shit, it's Salad Fingers.
We got something new.
We're going past 513.
We went past it.
Yay!
New record.
Salad Fingers.
God, first Doctor Horrible.
What does it say about you?
You recognize these references.
You recognize the references too.
There hasn't been anything with Brother yet.
I mean, there was one where he grew taller, right?
Oh no, no.
He exploded.
Just kidding.
Yeah, he exploded.
Why did the Brother explode?
Not just once, but three times.
I don't think there's actually one in here.
I don't think so either.
I don't see anything.
There's no faces on the floor.
And someone gave me a blue super chat and was like, Akasupa.
Wait, does that mean there's an anomaly or there's no anomaly?
Does blue mean safe?
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Swipe or no swiping?
Alright, let's wait.
This is the right elevator.
There's no anomalies.
Why are you having me press it?
I haven't pressed it.
You made up the rule!
What?
That made up the rule!
What do you mean?
515.
Has there been one that we haven't done yet?
That we haven't saw?
I think we haven't...
This one.
It's the blue screen.
This was the first one we got, I think.
It was a long time ago.
It threw us off because we saw it was real.
516.
And I think we haven't gotten the one with the lots of plugs, right?
No, we did.
You're the one that called it out.
We did the previous run though.
Oh, you're right.
Oh, you're right!
Yeah!
Or did we?
I can't remember.
Everything's blending together, you guys.
All these floors.
We went through so many floors.
No...
I don't know actually.
Brother, help!
Brother!
Brother, we don't know!
I think...
There's nothing here.
Are you sure?
You're trusting me now?
No, I mean I'm not trusting you.
Brother...
Guys, I don't know.
If we fuck up, we go back to zero.
All the way to zero.
You don't want to go back to zero, guys!
You don't!
Here we go!
Wait, why am I pressing it?
Because I pressed it last time!
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Come on.
Come on!
SCP!
You...
No, chat.
What did we miss?
There was no anomalies!
Did we go to the wrong elevator?
No, no we didn't.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
This is the first level.
No, what did we...
Oh, wait, someone said review.
We can go review it.
What did we do?
Okay, now we have to review.
What did we miss?
No way.
No way!
What did we...
There was no anomalies!
Nobody super chatted us!
It was the door.
We got that one.
It was like the first one we got.
Yeah!
Nobody super chatted us!
No smiley!
No one else noticed!
Nobody noticed!
245.
Two...
There's...
Is it like a time thing?
Like with the head, you know?
Like we weren't looking in the right direction?
Someone said... what?
Under the shelf?
Is it this box?
The...
That thing looks weird!
Oh my god!
What?
Look up.
Up?
Where?
Look up.
Look up?
Oh!
No!
Are you kidding me?
You see it?
Is it the 6666666666?
Look up at the box too!
Look up!
It's this box right here!
They said look up!
There's 6666 label!
Oh my god!
Here too!
Chat didn't know either.
Chat didn't know, there was no...
super chat.
Chat didn't know either.
You can't blame it on us!
We gave it!
There's like- oh all the bottles say 6662.
Well they used to say ethanol and- I thought there would only be one 666 because it's the...
They baited us!
They always always did one, and now it's like several?
Now it's two?
This is messed up.
It's not our fault guys.
It's never the streamers fault.
One chat member got the labels right.
No, this is so messed up.
One guy in the correct direction.
The one guy was actually correct.
What is this?
Oh my god.
And on the final thing!
On the final line!
That was so cheesy!
That was so cheap.
Oh my god, that was so cheap.
We were so happy getting to the sixth...
Bro, we're stuck at 500 forever.
Forever?
It's okay, we can speedrun.
We know everything now.
We know them all.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We knew everything.
Speedrun, speedrun, speedrun.
Okay.
What is it?
666!
It's 666!
On the...
Wrong elevator.
I saw you.
I saw you run over there.
I saw it.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, we got this.
Okay.
We got...
Wait, what's 666?
Was it on the trash can or the labels?
It was on the trash can.
Okay, okay.
I'm keeping track so we can like...
If we get all the anomalies left, then we can just press...
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
Okay.
Not us being like so excited for some of these.
We're gonna have to get the box one all over again too.
Oh no!
Alright.
I know how to do this faster.
How?
One person goes?
Yeah.
Okay.
Here I go.
There I go.
I'm not a damn bitch.
It's gonna force you in here once there's Johnny.
It's the bags.
It's the bags?
See?
Look at how fast it is.
It's like you just press the button when you're...
What if I'm here?
What if it's a non...
What if it's nothing?
What if you have to go all the way back?
I'm gonna lie to you at some point.
I'm gonna tell you.
We all wanna leave the hospital.
If you lie, it'll be a lie.
It affects you too.
Here we go.
It's the boxes.
No, really?
I'm coming out.
I'm leaving.
I'm getting out of here.
Really?
The boxes?
I'm coming out.
Wait, I thought you were an expert on this.
What happened?
I'm coming out.
Yeah?
Any second now?
I'm coming out.
Do you see the boxes like getting pushed from the...
I come out!
I'm coming out.
The box is gonna disappear soon.
It's the box.
Do you see?
I'm kicking them one by one.
I'm coming out.
Oh!
Oh, there you are.
It disappear didn't it?
No, it didn't.
You didn't do it yourself.
No, I didn't.
I punched my way out.
You did not do it yourself.
Oh my god.
Here we go.
I'm on my way!
You got this!
Go Min-go!
Stookie is too much of a baby!
I am not a baby!
I am trying to be efficient here!
I'm not a baby!
Uh, I think... wait hold on let me check the labels.
No, not really?
Okay.
Check the smiles.
Smiley's, Smiley's, Smiley's.
Smiley's on the light switch?
Yes.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh my god.
We fucked up floor 500 like four times already.
No, it was like three!
It was like three.
Oh, now you can count.
I think this is our third run.
Now you can count.
Oh, no actually you don't.
This is our fourth run.
This is actually our fourth run.
It is?
For real?
No way.
I'm with you this time because I think it's no anomaly time.
I think you're right.
Um...
I'm double checking here.
Double checking everything.
Okay, you're right.
See?
I'm so good at gambling.
Probability wise, I was right.
This game...
Okay.
Oh my god it's so intense now.
Oh god, it's so intense.
Oh, Brother is exploding!
Brother is exploding!
Oh, this time it's a close one!
Alright.
Exploding Brother.
We are missing the label six.
Bye Brother.
The label, the baby, the six plugs and the body heads.
Wait.
And the face.
The labels, the baby... The floor...
Oh, the face.
Face on the ground, salad fingers.
No label.
See, I'm helping now.
Yeah, because we're close.
Yeah, now we have to go all the way to the other one.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think we're good.
Go all the way down.
The hinges.
Yep, it's correct.
Okay.
We almost... Ooh, that was close.
Oh, yeah.
I'm used to checking it on the way to running there.
Yeah, from this side.
Yeah, we got Johnny.
We need Johnny.
Okay.
Don't hit the floor.
We're good.
Unless... I think it like slowly starts to appear though.
So we might have to like...
Wait a second.
Which one?
The floor?
Yeah, like it's the... It's like the fade in.
Like the QR code.
Oh, like the QR code.
Yeah.
I'm checking all.
Um...
Nothing on the floor.
Labels.
Labels are disinfectant.
Um...
Do we got the... Do we get the heads at the trash can yet?
Yeah, we already got that one.
Oh, okay.
So we don't have to care about that.
Alright, no anomalies.
So I think we're good.
Yeah.
I think we're good.
No anomalies.
Check the door.
The door is good.
We're good.
Okay.
We're getting better.
It only took us four tries, but we're getting better now.
Yes.
Oh, my God.
Bing.
Yes.
Okay.
Oh, baby.
Baby.
Baby Holy shit.
I want him to look at me this time.
His eyes kind of look to the right.
You're right.
What's wrong with us anymore?
We need to get the floor 666 you guys.
I've been playing this game for three hours.
We're close to four hours.
Oh the door hinges.
We also gotta worry about the door hinges.
666 labels!
666 labels are...
Alright, nice.
Alright.
513!
I think the door hinges are gonna be like the last one.
There's nothing on the floor.
Wait, what are we missing?
We're missing the floor.
We're missing the...
Door hinge.
I think nothing.
And also the one of all the...
There's nothing, so I think we're good.
I think we're good.
Back to there.
We're back to there.
We still have a whole other floor.
We still have three more.
Why did you suggest this?
I didn't.
Why did you agree to this?
Fourteen.
It should be... last three, right?
I think so.
Last three, so it's all anomalies.
No, this one... unless it's the floor.
It's the floor.
It's all three, so it's all how much you want to bet.
Do you really want to do this?
Yeah, let's do it.
It's literally all anomalies.
You know I'm right.
Okay, we'll do it.
What are we missing?
We're missing the door hinge.
And we're missing the six.
We can see from here.
It's the six plugs.
How much you want to bet.
Okay.
Six plugs.
Okay, do it.
Yeah, do it.
I'm going to do it.
Do it.
This is six plugs.
All right.
The moment of truth.
Do it.
And it's the door hinge.
I can see it.
I told you.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, that pause though.
I literally held my breath.
I couldn't...
I was like, please be right.
I told you.
I'm so... Oh my gosh, it's the back rooms.
Where are the back rooms?
I'm in...
Oh!
Is it me?
It's me.
I'm literally the sacrifice man.
You guys do this.
I'm trying to find it.
I don't know what to do.
Oh my gosh.
It's right there.
I sacrificed myself.
Oh my gosh.
It's after me.
No.
It's the door.
He has to break it.
He has to break it first.
What is this bullshit?
How do we lead him to that?
Let's see it.
You can clutch this.
You clutch all...
How do I do it?
I don't know.
I don't...
Oh my gosh.
You're gaming.
Game of the year.
Why do I always survive?
Did he just sigh?
Did he just go...
This is it.
Oh my gosh.
600.
600 baby, 600.
We're almost there.
Brother!
Okay, it's the operation room.
Wow, there's a lot going on in here.
Oh my god, okay.
And then there's an opera.
There's another x-ray over here that we can't go in.
Okay.
There's x-rays, there's...
There's a calendar here.
May, June, we care about your health.
Okay, nice.
I think I absorbed everything in.
Okay.
There's a computer.
The computer, the screen is off.
Final stretch, baby.
The final stretch.
Let's just do it.
We'll learn as we go.
That's how we did it in floor 500, baby.
Why can't this one be in the middle of the room?
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Brother.
All the screens are off.
Nothing...
No sixes anywhere.
I think it's...
No anomaly.
Oh my god, why am I glitching so bad?
I don't see any anomalies anywhere.
Oh yeah, me too.
Oh, is that a glitch?
Or is that an anomaly?
Is that an anomaly?
I think... oh, I'm glitching so much.
Even now.
Wow!
I think that's an anomaly.
Is that an anomaly?
Wow!
That has to be an anomaly.
There's no way.
There's no way, right?
I mean, we're in 601.
It doesn't matter.
That has to be an anomaly.
It has to be.
Yay!
That was cool.
That was a cool anomaly.
Yeah, I thought we were lagging.
I was like, whoa.
Oh, Brother scares me every time, man.
Uh...
That was such a creative anomaly, though.
Yeah, that one's fun.
Because you can't tell if it's kusoge or...
Yeah, or just...
You're the game itself.
May, June, July.
We care about your health.
Disease history.
Nothing.
I don't see anything.
I don't see anything either.
I think we're actually good this time.
An anomaly.
Oh my god.
Don't fuck with us like that.
I'm checking now, though.
I'm checking!
603.
We have to check the labels, too.
Just to see if there's any sixes.
603!
603, baby!
Let's go!
I think Brother's gonna be standing at one point.
Yeah, me too.
Or he's gonna change his face.
Okay, he's fine right now.
Nothing on the monitors.
Nothing on the side.
Nothing in the operating.
No 666 anywhere.
I'm checking.
We care about your health.
May, June, July.
It's the same date.
History.
There's no way that there's nothing here.
I don't know.
We could get two in a row.
No anomalies.
That's the secret one.
No anomalies for twice.
I don't think so.
Alright.
Wait, did they not hear that?
Hear what?
They're fucking with you.
There's no way.
What was that noise?
What do you mean?
I don't hear anything.
Oh, that's you.
That's me.
They said hole on the bed?
What?
There's always been a hole here.
What hole?
There's always been a hole there.
This hole?
Was that a girl?
I'm scared now.
What?
That's always been there.
Oh, this hole here.
It's always been there.
What do you mean?
Hold on.
Ah!
Wow.
Very realistic.
Look, we've been playing for almost four hours.
I can't dedicate a voice for it.
Let's just go.
Okay, anyway.
Up we go.
I'm aware 603.
There's no way.
At best, we retry three floors.
It's better than not.
True, true, true.
It's better than...
Okay, let's see if there's a hole on the bed.
Let's see.
There was no hole on the bed.
There's no hole on the bed.
We were like, there's always been a hole.
We were thinking of like the fucking chiropractor.
Massages.
I forgot this is an operating table.
No, operating tables do have holes in the bed.
Sometimes they have holes, right?
Yeah, for brain surgery.
I don't know.
I thought it was there to keep your head comfy.
Me too.
Okay, well now we know.
Whoa, whoa, it's a game to game.
Oh, whoa.
Whoa, it's us.
Oh, it's you.
It's following you.
It's my POV.
It's your POV.
Guys, at least it was like three floors.
Yeah, it's fine.
Now we know.
And then we call chat crazy.
We're like, guys, there's always been a hole.
You're crazy.
I'm the protagonist.
They were like, literally, they were like, there's a hole there.
We're like, oh, yeah.
Yeah, of course.
We said it so confidently.
I know.
We were so like, yeah, it's a hole.
Oh my god.
All operating tables have a hole in it.
Yeah.
I don't think I see anything here.
History mmm.
History mmm is there.
There's no 666.
Brother, we've been doing this for a while now, brother.
Brother please.
Brother.
Brother ugh.
Okay.
But like, also chat was gaslighting us while telling us there's a hole.
Yeah, they were saying exactly.
Did you hear that?
Of course we're gonna think that.
We think that everything is wrong.
No, we didn't hear anything.
There's no sixes.
Oh, well.
Is there anything on the other side?
We care about your health.
May, June, July.
The labels are normal.
Labels are normal.
The x-rays are normal too.
There's...
There's no hole on the wall this time.
I thought I heard like a beeping, but it might have been like just omniscience.
Yeah, I know.
I think it's omniscience.
I didn't hear a beeping.
Okay, we go to the other side.
No hollering.
Alright.
No, it's not your fault chat.
It's the whole mess.
Oh, okay.
It wasn't your chat that pointed it out.
Or anything, you know.
And you chose to ignore it.
You chose to ignore it.
Your chat said...
All your chat said was, did you hear the noise?
My chat actually called the hole in the bed.
They probably heard me like humming and were just like, uh oh.
That wasn't normal.
Obvious.
They were just trying to be helpful.
They were just trying to...
I don't...
I don't see anything.
I can't see...
Vitamin complex.
There's no 666.
We care about your health.
May, June, July.
I'm looking to see if any heads pop up.
Door hinges are good.
Wait.
See if there's lag.
Oh yeah.
No.
No lag.
So here?
Is it none?
The floor.
What about the floor?
Don't gaslight us.
Oh my god!
The wires say 666!
666!
I saw it before you.
No, I saw it.
Cause I trust my chat.
I saw it in my chat.
I noticed that they were in perfect circles, but I thought he just copied and pasted them.
I thought he was being a lazy dev.
After 600 floors?
This is the part where he gets lazy?
Don't worry, Wisps.
I know you guys saw it first.
Don't worry, Dragoons.
I knew you...
When you guys said 666, I knew you guys were right.
You guys were so good.
Cause I trust my chat.
I... yeah.
Hole in the bed.
Alright, we know.
Hole in the bed is gone.
Yeah, hole in the bed is gone, everybody.
We got hole in the bed out of the way.
We're so fucking confident.
Oh god.
We were like scolding our chat.
There's always hole in the bed.
606.
Oh my god, that's 10 away.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
I was gonna say 10 away from 666.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Wait.
Look!
Brother!
Brother is being polite!
Brother is...
Brother is talking to someone, I think.
Oh, brother.
Okay.
We're going.
Brother's been in this hospital a bit too long.
Brother finally is speaking.
Alright, up we go.
He's laying right now.
He's like flirty with whoever he's talking to.
I don't know who he's talking to.
He's like, hey.
I know.
I like...
I don't want that anomaly again if we fuck up.
I can't wait to get flirty brother back.
I miss flirty brother.
Um, there's Raiden in the operating room.
What the fuck is that?
I don't know.
Why is he huge?
I triple dog dare you to go see him.
Yeah, go up to him.
We gotta do this again if we...
No, not necessarily.
Wait, he just... She's like half clipped to the floor.
What's she gonna do?
Phase through and kill me?
She might.
I'm leaving.
Oh.
What happened to moral support?
I never said that.
Oh, now you're not gonna support me morally.
I'm never supported you morally.
Raiden, turn off the game console.
Alright.
608.
We're getting there.
Woo, woo, woo, woo, woo, woo.
We're missing the monitor and the lab.
Uh, there's a baby in the...
There's a baby?
There's a child.
Baby in it out.
He's not moving.
Baby.
Wait, what?
He's counting down.
93.
92.
Okay, we have like 100 seconds.
100 seconds.
Why does he sound like that though?
95.
94.
93.
Somebody put baby in the corner.
609, baby.
Woo.
Hopefully there's no baby.
Alright, we got one baby.
Every floor has a baby.
No.
No, nothing in the monitor.
Oh, I'm lagging.
I'm lagging.
Are you?
I think so.
I'm not.
Oh, maybe.
No, I'm not.
I bumped into you, maybe.
Oh, maybe.
Yeah, I'm okay.
I'm walking back and forth.
Okay, okay, nevermind.
Um...
We care about your health.
May, June, July.
Disease, history, mm.
I don't see anything.
I don't see anything either.
Nothing on the labels.
All the labels are not 666.
I think we're fine.
Yay, we're at the closer door!
We're at the closer x-ray!
I'm trusting you.
Okay, then you go back into the room then.
I'm scared.
Then you go back into the room.
You're gonna trust me.
And you're not confident enough.
I'm scared.
I don't know.
I'm nervous.
I'm so nervous!
I feel like usually the things are...
I don't know.
Okay, I...
People are like, blood?
But like they're not even confident about it.
They're saying like, is that blood by the brother?
But I don't see anything at all.
There's blood by the brother?
I don't think so.
I think they're...
They're being way too specific.
Yeah, there's blood.
What?
What are you talking about?
Where?
Behind the brother?
There's no blood anywhere.
There's no blood by the...
Are we really...
On the cabinet door?
What?
Okay, I'm pretty sure.
I'm so confused.
I am...
I am confused too.
Huh?
I'm trying to see.
I'm trying to look around to see if we missed anything.
Blood inside you.
That's a medic bag.
I'm dead.
Alright, that's ectoplasm.
Get it right.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I mean, if we get this right, it's 610.
We just... just rip off the bandaid, man.
Just rip off the bandaid.
Come on.
Oh my god!
Thank god!
Oh thank god!
Oh my god!
Thank you!
Ah!
What just happened?
Oh.
Um, hello?
Where are you?
I'm in exit 8!
No way.
You're in exit 8?
You got teleported?
Yes, I'm in exit 8!
I wanna get teleported.
I'm in exit 8 too.
Oh, hey!
No way.
Keep left.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
We're in exit 8!
Aren't we supposed to go backward if it's...
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
We go back.
We go back cause it's anomaly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's actually exit 8!
Oh my god.
We got easy guide to exit 8.
Oh, we're back.
Wait, we're back?
Oh, we're back!
Okay, I think that's anomaly, guys.
I don't know about that one.
Is it the same dev?
No, it's a different dev.
It's a parody.
That's so funny.
We got easy guide to exit 8.
Some of these, like, anomalies are pretty good.
Yeah, they're actually pretty funny.
Oh, wait.
I think I'm lagging.
I think this is lag.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, is it?
Unless we just pushed each other weird.
Okay, I'm going inside.
Oh, I'm going inside.
Oh, wait.
I'm lagging.
No, no, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It is.
Ooh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm trying to get out.
Let me out.
I see it pushes you back.
Oh, my god.
Oh, I still can't believe I got teleported to exit 8.
I know.
That was crazy.
That was a good one.
You didn't even want to join me.
I went in.
Okay.
Let's see.
Is there any 666?
I'm now paranoid for any 666 references.
I know, right?
Oh, my god.
Ever since...
I know.
...room 515.
I'll never forget 515.
I'll never forgive.
Never forget.
915, 516.
I'll never forget 516.
This one looks good, I think.
Yeah, I think so, too.
Anything behind the brother?
Just for chat's sake.
Where's the blood?
All right.
I think we're good.
That's so much fun.
I'm fine.
Yeah.
All right.
Heading to the other side.
No.
We have to head to the other side.
Dokie checked the labels, right?
You checked the labels?
Sure.
Time to look at the numbers, Minx.
Time to look at the numbers.
Time to look at the...
I'm gained.
This is your fault.
How is it my fault?
Yeah.
This is your fault.
This is my fault.
I'm food.
This is food.
This is your fault!
You said you checked!
We're reviewing!
Oh my god...
We're not getting stuck in...
We're not getting stuck in... What was it?
What was it?
The labels?
No?
They're fine.
Is it the x-rays?
Were they supposed to be closer together?
The calendar?
We care about your health.
I think that's what it says.
Is the x-rays supposed to be closer together?
Look up.
There's nothing up top.
What was it?
Wait, actually... the plugs?
Wait, what do you mean the plugs?
Oh my god...
Oh!
It's the walls.
Oh my god!
I just saw them!
That is so cheeky!
Oh my god!
It doesn't appear!
Oh!
They're making it really obvious.
I can't believe we didn't see that!
Oh my god!
We're at six!
It's because they don't appear soon enough!
They don't appear soon enough.
Oh no... Alright, go to the other one.
Speedrunnersbane.
Zero.
This is zero.
Give it up for the four hours!
We're gonna make it!
Oh my god, you're actually right!
Four hours!
Four hours of this game!
Give it up for hour number four!
No...
Okay, we got majority anomalies this time.
Yeah, it's true.
We get to see Flirty Guy again.
Oh yeah, we get to see Flirty Brother again!
I miss Flirty Brother.
Wait, it's the same.
Maybe it's a win.
It's the walls.
Oh wait, it's the walls.
Are you sure?
Yeah.
Oh, you're right!
Yeah, it is the walls.
Good, good, good.
We got it out of the way.
I got it out of the way.
I was like, are my eyes deceiving me?
Because I...
Because we went through that.
Oh my god...
In another world, it would have been like five floors left.
In another world...
Why couldn't they be the first one last time too?
Right?
Anomaly, Anomaly, come over here.
I'm speedrunning.
I see it.
I saw it.
Then monitor.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hey, we get to do Exit 8 again!
Oh yeah!
That was fun.
Yeah.
I wonder if it would be the same one.
The same Anomaly.
With the poster.
Oh, maybe.
Probably, right?
Yeah, probably.
Unless they coded, like, several.
The one I don't want... I don't like the lagging one.
It hurts my brain.
Oh, the lagging one was freaky.
There's no 666.
Because we're missing some Anomaly's that we haven't got.
Yeah.
There's a few.
So like, I'm worried.
But I think this one's okay.
I don't think so.
Yeah, I think this one's okay.
I think we're good.
Yeah.
To the next floor!
Next floor!
I won.
Discord lag.
Alright, here we go.
I didn't realize this was a competition.
You held your note for a long time.
I assumed that we were trying to beat you.
No, I mean, that's...
That's what you would assume, isn't it?
No 666 on the floor.
No baby.
No baby and nothing seems odd.
No hole in the...
No hole in the thing.
Yeah, I think we're fine.
I think we're good.
Yeah, we're good.
Are we?
Yeah!
Ceiling?
What's wrong with the ceiling?
They always say ceiling.
They really do.
They always do.
They never stop with the ceiling.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, here we go.
We're so close.
6-0-5!
Less than... more than 10 left.
11 left.
Go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, brother.
Nothing, no cables.
Everything's fine.
No sixes.
Care about your health.
Labels are fine.
May, June, July.
No history.
Ceiling, nothing.
It says exit here.
I think we're good.
There's no hole in the wall.
Let's go.
Really?
Two in a row?
Two in a row.
The game's being nice to us.
Let's go.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm worried about the one thing that's like...
Because we haven't seen three anomalies.
Yeah, I know.
So it's like, what could the three...
What could the three be?
6-0-6!
Yes!
10 more!
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run!
It's...
Zesty Brother!
Wait, no, never mind.
Oh, it's the monitor, it's the monitor!
Oh, the monitor.
Again?
Didn't we get the monitor before?
There's two different ones, right?
There was?
I think so.
How did we not...
I thought we already did the brother.
Not the brother, the monitor.
Yeah, I thought we already did the monitor.
Let's hear Smoker Baby!
I think the next one will be the baby!
Baby in the corner!
Baby, baby, baby.
Oh, a predator is too.
Nice.
Okay.
Because I was like, I don't remember seeing two.
Oh, no baby in the corner.
It's a cable, it's a cable.
6-6-6.
Why can't it be the closer elevator, goddammit!
Goddammit, give us the closer one!
Wow, someone's so slow today.
Nah, I have a bug that's flying in my face.
Oh no.
Does the bug know about 6-6-6?
I killed it.
Oh, what, with your hand?
I thought you were a ghost!
I killed it just now.
Is it a ghost bug?
It is now.
Nothing here.
Oh, it's the lady!
It's Raiden!
Raiden, Raiden, Raiden!
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Turn off the game console!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we're doing it again.
We're doing it, we're doing it well.
We're speedrunning, we're so good now!
Woooo!
It's okay.
6-0-9!
Seven more!
Oh my god.
Zesty brother, zesty brother, zesty brother.
Nope.
Baby?
Hole in the bed, hole in the bed, hole in the bed!
Let's go, let's go!
We punch each other.
Get out!
We need to get to 6-6-6!
We're like, okay we found it, go, go, go!
Go, go, go, go!
Alright.
There we go.
I wonder if you failed the exit 8, do I lose?
I don't know.
Like before, right?
Yeah, yeah, cause we got it right before.
We still have the lag.
No baby.
Wait, the camera.
What the fuck?
Oh, I saw it, I saw it!
Oh!
Oh my god, that's so weird.
That's like the camera, the dead POV.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well that's kinda fun.
Yeah, that's fun.
Alright.
Someone needs to work out more there.
I was looking at it!
Do not wanna leave the hospital!
I'm enjoying my time!
It's literally a camera.
Alright.
Zesty brother, zesty brother, zesty brother, zesty brother, zesty brother, zesty brother, zesty brother.
Maybe in the corner, maybe in the corner.
Baby in the corner!
Baby in the corner, we just have brother and exit 8.
And that's all the ones we've seen, right?
Yeah.
99.
Are you f- I was like, where did you go?
92.
89.
What happened?
That's because we count to zero.
That's what I'm wondering.
I swear to god, I swear to god.
We have to go back to 6.
Will it be worth it?
You want me in the elevator?
Go closer to that room!
Go closer!
What did he say?
What?
He stopped clowning.
I don't think he expects us to stay here.
I don't think he does.
He just stomps at them.
He got lazy!
I told you, lazy Dev!
Lazy Dev!
He doesn't even fucking count all the way to the end!
If you don't get counted all the way to the end, start from 10!
I know, right?
Dev got tired.
He was like, well you're supposed to be gone.
Oh, oh.
Exit A?
Yeah, exit A.
Exit A.
Okay, I'm gonna see if you...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
What?
I wanna see you pop into existence.
Oh, okay, okay, I can do that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, it's an anomaly!
Is it the same one?
Yeah, it's the same one.
Oh, okay.
Let's see what you look like when you pop back in.
Here I go.
Where are you?
I'm coming back.
Oh, I'm here.
It's this way.
Oh, it's this way.
He just popped beside me.
Okay, up we go.
Who are we missing?
Three more!
Oh, we're missing Zesty Brother.
Oh, and then I think two others, right?
Yeah, two others we haven't seen before.
Oh, and Lag.
I don't think we got the Lag one yet.
Oh, we didn't get the Lag one.
Okay, so then we have one anomaly that we haven't got before.
Alright.
Okay, okay, okay, we got this, we got this.
Nope.
Oh, oh, oh!
Is it Lag?
No, no, no, look, look, look.
It's like unfinished textures.
No textures.
Oh yeah!
Oh, everything has no textures!
Oh my god!
Oh, so everything has to be anomaly now.
Everything is a PNG.
No, no, no.
Okay, 14.
Oh wait, no, we're missing one.
No, I think it's better to... yeah.
We're missing one because we have...
We have to check.
We have done two, so...
Yeah, yeah, we have to check.
Okay, it's fine.
Lazy Dev.
Alright, here we go.
My immersion!
This isn't a video game, this is real life.
I'm stuck in the game, please help!
Yeah, we're stuck in the hospital!
It's the brother!
Zesty Brother!
He's having a good time.
Okay, nice.
Okay, Lag and then...
Unknown.
Alright.
Off we go.
Not... we didn't take the wrong elevator too.
We did it.
No.
We didn't take the wrong elevator.
We're good.
We got this, we got this, we got this.
We got this, we got this.
How we can't fuck it up now?
It's gotta be the Lag, right?
Yeah, it has to be the Lag.
Or something else.
Or no anomaly.
Um, run around to see if we lag at all?
No lag.
Oh, wait.
I don't like this because we don't...
We don't know.
Wait, I don't like this because it's not lag.
It's too much of a mystery!
This is a mystery.
Any success?
The labels?
The labels are fine.
Looking at the calendar.
Medical center first.
We care about your health.
May, June, July.
There's no 666.
Oh no.
Nothing with the table, the bed.
Disease history.
There's no 6 rays.
Nothing with the x-rays.
They all look the same.
The walls aren't smiling this time.
No.
I don't like this, Mint.
I don't like this either.
The wall was the first one we got.
Yeah.
The x-rays are okay.
There's no 666.
Nothing on the ceiling.
I don't know, man.
Is there no one behind Lisa's door?
I
think we're good.
Okay.
I'll press the button.
I'll take the blame.
Wait, what?
It's a lag.
We don't have to do this.
Yeah, I said it's a lag.
A lag.
I'm lagging in the elevator.
It's definitely...
This is it.
Good luck, Mint.
Oh.
We're at the...
What floor are we at?
666!
We're here.
Here we go.
Just run for it.
There's no...
Wait, the elevator's not open though.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
I think something is gonna come from that elevator.
No, but then like... Oh.
Maybe you're right.
I think we need to turn around.
I think you're right.
Oh.
Whoa.
Was that a PNG?
Yeah, that was a PNG.
I think we just got a...
There's a wheelchair.
The sheet goes.
It's your cousin.
It's my cousin.
Let's run.
Oh, it's the body bag.
It's the body bag.
It's just a normal guy.
It's Anita.
It's a normal guy.
Oh my god.
How did I die?
How did you die?
I don't know.
I think we have to like...
As soon as it starts ringing, we gotta...
We gotta turn around.
Oh, that's true.
Wait, that means he's faster than us.
That's messed up.
Yeah, stop there.
Okay.
There we go.
Turn around.
We wasted too much time.
No, no, no.
Don't stop.
Don't look back.
You're... You're... You're...
I'll punch you to victory.
I'll punch you.
I'll punch you if you get too close.
Okay.
Punch me.
I'll punch you if you get too close.
Normal guy.
You're doing normal things.
Oh my god.
Are you punching me?
I'm punching.
Yes, I am.
Stop laughing.
I'm punching you.
I'm not laughing.
I'm doing my best.
Oh, it worked.
It worked.
I'm doing my best.
Don't die.
I said I wouldn't do it.
I sacrificed my life.
I did everything I could.
I'm punching.
Oh my god.
It's a doctor.
He's right there.
Holy shit.
He was right behind us.
We did it.
Complete normal mode.
Oh my god.
It was a doctor.
He wanted to get paid.
I like how this entire Critics is this one guy.
Marketing manager.
Cell manager.
Developer.
YouTube anomaly acting.
School666.
Oh, I know what we're playing next time.
Oh my god.
Wait, are we going to classroom 6?
How are we gonna do... Is it gonna be floors?
Wasn't there an easy mode to this?
Yeah, the easy mode is that there's a routine.
So like...
Wait.
What?
Wait, we're still here.
I got an achievement too that was just like you escaped the hospital.
But have you really?
Wait, there's more?
Yeah, but like...
But like...
What is the hard... What?
What's the difference?
I don't know.
What's the difference, Mint?
Just keep going.
Just go to the next...
Go to the elevator.
It says exit.
I thought it was over.
It's fine.
Just keep going.
I thought it... But it's back to zero.
No, no.
It's back to zero.
It's fine.
We're fine.
It's back to zero.
It's all good.
Oh no.
I don't understand.
What would be different?
I think the game is over.
I think the game is over too.
I think...
I think there's a return to menu button up here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I see it too.
I see it.
You see that menu?
Oh my god.
It just showed up.
I got into the elevator and the return to menu button showed up.
Did you see that?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my... I'm in the menu.
Oh, you left.
No, it like showed up.
She's gone, you guys.
She's gone.
I'm going to the next floor.
You're going to the next...
Are you actually?
There's like a giant hand print.
What are these?
Giant...
Is that you?
That's me.
That's the anomaly.
How did you do that?
Wait, how did you do that?
You were over there.
Wait, they're both orange.
They're both orange light.
Which is the OG.
No, they're not.
That one's only one that's orange.
That one's orange for me.
They're both orange.
I think you fucked up.
I think I fucked up the light.
Yeah.
I think you messed it up.
Everything is like light now.
It's so bright.
This has to be the hard mode, right?
So let's go to the menu.
I'm going to go to the menu and see if it's on the menu.
It has to be the hard mode.
But like, what's the hard mode though?
Let's see.
New game.
Oh yeah, it's Hell.
Return to floor 000 if you fail.
Oh, it's the same.
It's just that you go back to zero.
Okay, so we finished.
We beat the game.
Wait, is this actually?
But is it...
It basically like instead of returning back to like, uh, like, you know, instead of returning back to like, floor 100, floor 200, floor 300, it goes back to zero.
Yeah, but is it also different floors?
I don't think so.
I'm starting a new game.
Are you fucking...
I'm curious.
Go some balls.
Well, you have to host the game.
You have to host it.
Oh, it's...
No, it's bloody.
It's bloody.
So yeah, the hard mode is the bloody mode.
Yeah, I would assume it is.
We did it!
We beat the game!
It only took us four hours.
What's the speedrun of this?
speedrun.com hospital It took us less than four hours.
You're right, because we had one hour of set up times.
Yeah, one hour to set up times.
And also, it's not been four hours yet.
It's been... not yet.
It's been one week since we...
Wait!
Oh my god!
We can be in the...
We can get in!
There's only...
We should submit our runs to speedrun.com.
There's only two participants.
Yo!
We're gonna be at the leaderboards!
We're at the leaderboards!
First place is the creator.
Stop it.
I think that's cheating.
That is actual cheating.
I like how First place is the creator.
What's his time?
30 minutes?
34 minutes?
That's not fair!
Not even fair.
It's not the creator!
It's some other guy!
I messed up.
It's not the creator.
I thought it was the creator because I saw Hong Kong.
Because I know that Dev is from Hong Kong.
Maybe it's a friend.
He fed the answers.
You're right!
It was one month ago.
We could be the third and fourth place.
If I submit first, I get third place.
Oh my god, Dokie.
The creator of that background just followed me on Twitter.
Wait, we're on the laundry mat?
Laundry mat?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna like the laundry mat.
Go get the laundry mat!
In fact, I'll follow the mat.
You have to use the laundry mat now.
You have to.
When will we get...
How did they know?
When will we get meaning that ghost girl at the laundry mat roleplay?
ASMR.
I will get the laundry mat.
I'll get the laundry mat background, everybody.
When will we get Laundromat ASMR RP?
I'm a maid.
I belong in the laundry room.
Oh god.
I'm tired.
This was fun.
And it was a team effort.
With the wisps and the dragoons working together.
The wisp goons.
Team effort.
We all did this together, guys.
Good job, everybody.
Good job, team.
Especially the dragoons.
The wisps helped like crazy, crazy.
Yeah.
Even though Mint didn't believe you sometimes, dragoons, like the hole in the bed.
Laugh.
Oh yeah.
But I know Doki kind of doubts you guys all the time.
But it's okay.
I always believed.
Did you agree?
Laugh.
Good job, everybody.
Good job, guys.
Good job, every wisps.
Good job, every dragoons.
You guys did it.
Remember the time stamp.
Whoever gets the most correct, guys.
Okay.
Whoever gets the most correct, then what is it?
What do we get?
What do we have to do?
We have to...
What's the punishment?
I don't know.
Okay, we decide the punishment later.
Oh, you decide?
You want to decide?
Only if you know.
Are you not confident?
Are you not confident that you're going to win?
No, I'm pretty confident.
I'm pretty confident.
You're pretty confident?
Then you decide something right now.
You're the one who was like, we'll decide later.
Yeah, because we don't know.
We don't know the result.
You're so confident.
Loser has to use the other person's gamer subs code.
Okay, deal.
Deal.
Let me grab...
Let me buy the free pack.
Laugh.
The free sample pack.
Oh, no.
Oh, GG's guys.
GG's everybody.
Are you going to chat with your wisp?
Because I'm just going to head off.
We did a long stream.
I'll chat just a little bit, but not very much.
GG's man.
GG's.
Bye bye.
We did it.
We survived.
Alright.
I'm really tired now.
I didn't think we would play for hours.
But that was so fun.
That was really, really, really fun.
I hope you guys enjoyed it a lot.
I am going to head out now.
Because I'm really tired.
And actually have a lot of stuff to do.
I'm doing last minute, last minute skin suit stuff.
So I hope you guys had a great time everybody.
That was a very fun game.
And I just want to say as always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause the video.
Watch the check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you except for me, head to Ben.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.